wow
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody looks like
we got the lights right Friday night
yeah lights are right
I guess so yeah
[Laughter]
we're just kind of well like I said
we're still kind of farting around with
them
okay yeah that always happens even
though I never go over there and touch
that I don't know how it happens but you
know
but yeah so hey it's Friday night time
for the Sidetrack show this is always
fun and relaxed because I don't have to
go anywhere tomorrow and
we can just we're not going anywhere
tonight either so we're just gonna sit
around and drink yep so we're gonna um
introduce y'all to the weekend uh
weekend yes there's the weekend
you worked all week and now uh Friday
night so hopefully you won't have to
work
although it's [__] I imagine
most people have to work whenever
they're told to work probably working on
Saturday too
but um well I usually end up working on
Saturday yeah as well weekend is here
and uh
we're already started on some uh
grapefruit and uh
grapefruit and vodka got a red
grapefruit yeah so I've got the ruby red
grapefruit I hadn't had that in a long
time but that's just really good yeah I
know I saw it there and I was going that
looks good and that was a dollar store
excuse me a dollar store brand
huh pretty good huh it's good because
it's not super acidic yeah you know what
I mean like it's I like grapefruit juice
a lot but it's you know it's not like
real real tart it was kind of like a
half gallon size
container they got some good the only
one like three bucks for it so I said
I'll try it
like I said I can't even remember the
last time we had yeah grapefruit juice
and vodka
so uh
we're gonna uh looks like everybody's
already in here damn yeah I've got huge
crowds pouring in Bath House Zach
showing up
John's that's that's your name from now
on I hate it
bath house door
we should do a whole show about those
stories yeah I mean I don't have any
personally because I've never been to
one but yeah we'll put Gava Friday on in
the back that's the oh [__] that's
another round that's another song I need
to put on your playlist I forgot yeah I
gotta put angel on there because I keep
I think I had it on your old one but
when I went from because I used to have
um
Pandora and now I have Spotify I had it
on your Pandora list yeah I don't know I
forgot about it I didn't put it on
Spotify because I was asking you the
other day well what other songs you want
on your Spotify and you wanted you all
you said that was you wanted some more
Iron Maiden no one more juice please no
Judas Priest sorry yeah yeah put some
juice priest on there put some Merciful
Fate on there okay
I mean I'll tell you which ones put on
maybe tomorrow like if we go to the
bookstore tomorrow maybe I will end up
getting that Rob Halford biography
autobiography yeah because I mean I
still got all those coupons because I
got the Books a Million membership yeah
so it's like I might as well get it
while I'm because I kind of want to read
it I mean I have like a pile of books I
gotta get through but
you know
Camp guy said I had someone recognize
y'all's genetic replicant more human
than human t-shirt today he was working
at Costco yeah I always like when that
happens what happens he saw it because I
know where that came from right right
yeah we'll see what you always know that
that's like gonna be okay
Zach said I was actually no he probably
just didn't recognize the show as much
as you can recognize recognizing right
right right yeah yeah okay uh Zach says
I was actually reading up about bath
houses because I was bored once and it
was legit super interesting yeah I
always thought like the history of them
was super interesting that might so you
know that might actually be like an
interesting show to do maybe so you're
just saying you just went there to get
pampered right like a spa
a towel on your face
keep giving you pedicures you know what
I have never been in all my nearly 51
years of life yeah I have never been
to a spa like I never I never had like a
facial I never had a pedicure or nothing
like that well you know that girl who
was [__] escort and she was working
out of a damn [__] spot yeah so we
always kind of Wonder so yeah so
so this is kind of funny I don't think
we've told this story before you could
get a happy ending at the spot full
service
shut the door she'd be in there and
she'd let you [__] slam away at her
as long as you make any noise
and I don't think the other girls there
didn't even know what was going on but
she was doing it out of a spot yeah yeah
but so that's why so every time we go to
uh the Chinese buffet or the movie
theater where the Lake Square Mall is
right across the street from the mall is
like this little kind of strip mall or
like a bunch of little shops and stuff
and there's like a massage parlor over
there
and we're kind of wondering is that like
a legit massage parlor are there such a
thing as legit massage parlors or are
they all I was like because the windows
these are mostly rubbing tugs right it's
like because the windows are always like
tinted you know what I mean so you can't
like buddy in the parking lot and that
was another thing we noticed it's like
because Tom's always making a joke about
hey let's pop in there and get a rub and
tug or whatever yeah but it's just Kylie
in it yeah yeah and it's like I was like
one if that's a legitimate place of
business they probably get really sick
of like at least one person a day coming
in and ask them for a happy ending
they're like we don't do that okay or if
it really is that I have never I've
legitimately never seen a car in that
parking lot yeah I I know like it
they're going to park a lot next to it
that's what we were suspecting so I was
like it doesn't look like it's closed it
looks like it's still like operating
yeah but there's never anybody parked
there you never see anybody going in or
out yeah and so Tom's like well maybe
people don't want to get be seen going
in there so they Park in the like Barber
Shop
it's the weirdest thing ever that way
that way you know if the dude's wife
Drives By and sees the car what's the
car doing there you know is he getting
rubbing tug you're like yeah that
[__] yeah she comes in
he's sitting there
a little Chinese lady has his dick in
her hand
but yeah so I I don't know one of these
days would make it curious enough
but it's just like I never see anybody I
never see anybody in the parking lot
it's like really really weird it's
probably some old Chinese woman working
out of there maybe with like mysterious
[__] Chinese girls in the background
that's probably what it is
serious Chinese girl this little face is
popping out
yeah that's probably what it is well
where I grew up like not too far from
where I grew up in Daytona
there was a place I can't remember what
the name of it was it had like a funny
name I remember but
um it was for sure like a robin tug yeah
you could just tell by looking at that
outside of the place it looks like super
Florida's real time for that [__] they
they uh okay you know uh this is it's
kind of a trashy Place Florida they know
about it they only busted one uh do you
know uh um
[__] right across from koiwan in the
mall across the street from from the
mall that koiwan is in yeah they had a
big bust over in there about two years
ago yeah I remember you telling me about
that yeah it was uh it was a massage spa
but they had like about 12 Chinese girls
living in there
um
in in each little masseur's room they
lived in there I think it was mostly
Chinese girls some were American girls
living in there yeah and you know giving
Happy Endings and [__]
but they busted that place
it made it too obvious
too many of them and they were living in
there
yeah I mean you'd think if you're gonna
do because technically that's not legal
no
so that's the brothel right you kind of
have to make it look like you have to
make it look like it's a legitimate I
lived in there yeah but like I said I
kind of I always got the impression when
I was growing up and like I said maybe
it's because I grew up in Daytona which
is like super trashy but it's like I
always got the impression that every
single like massage place you saw was
that yeah I didn't think there was any
like normal one I've never been in one I
think they are
I've never been to one either I mean why
would I I was assumed that they're one
expensive to illicit yeah and you go in
there and they're gonna look at you
sideways and ask you a bunch of weird
questions trying to figure out who you
are how do you know about this place
that kind of [__] I always felt it would
be uncomfortable to go in there we
should like put we should like wear a
wire and go in there
just out of curiosity I just wanted to
know maybe some of them are legit well
here's the thing because we have
um friends who are a couple
and they are both massage therapists
yeah and I feel like they and they're
like legit massage therapists like you
know in the sense of people that get
like injured and then you know they're
trying to get back so they you know they
they have their tables and they go to
the people's houses and try to get all
their muscles back up to speed and
everything like that so I think she gets
kind of mad because every now and then
she because every now and then she does
get asked to do that and she's like look
I'm like a legitimate massage therapist
yeah I'm licensed and everything and
it's just you know what I mean and so
it's like
I'm sure you get like [__] chodes
every now and then that [__]
ask that yeah but I'm also sure that
they're
licensed massage therapists that give
happy endings too well yeah that's what
I'm saying I always thought that that's
what all of them were yeah you know
because I thought like a massage
therapist they would if you're a legit
massage therapist they'd probably call
the business something else yeah you
know I think they would um if you wanted
to get into in into the rubber tuck
business you go ahead and get your
credentials as licensed massage
therapist first so you have a cover
you're like what I'm just and then
massaging you have your regular
customers
and he said oh by the way I offered for
my very special customers here's my
[__] special menu here you know and
you have to like I would love to say
like if they if they would come up with
like really weird like euphemistic yeah
because everybody knows what a happy
ending is so you probably have to come
up with something like different wink
wink you know what I mean
murder Hornets is there
what do they say welcome to flash bulbs
oh see you joined again he joined
sometimes and then uh
John Gore said William friedkin R.I.P
yeah he just died last week I think
had a funny bathhouse story he was
trying to secure an authentic location
for cruising oh that's yeah that's a
good movie I just watched that not too
long ago actually uh this old wise guy's
house and they had to take it outside
because the place was bugged yeah that's
right I remember hearing about that
that's a good movie actually cruising
Zach says oh they do facials at the bath
house too but I don't think they're the
kind you're looking for I thought that
too like as soon as I said it
hahaha
I don't necessarily want to face it like
that at least not from like [__]
strangers right yeah
that would be a little yeah weird not
even on video you wait
it's like that one I have one video we
were watching the other day it was that
what porn star was that the one that had
the dudes like just
just I don't know we're judging all over
her face
uh this was been a long time ago no
wasn't it was just like a week or two
ago that's a long time ago for me
not a long time
[Laughter]
I don't remember who that was
I remember it was maybe it was Sophie D
or somebody like that we were watching a
couple of those and you were like yeah
I think it was Sophie D or something
that's just typical [__] that they do
Studio porn star chicks they just that's
just part of their deal well yeah they
just had like the same ring of dudes
coming yeah they just do that that's
part of the job description jacket off
they do that and then forget about it
they're like oh I forgot that I forgot
about that yeah well they probably do it
so many times and they're like [__]
[__]
what are you talking about you love it
you love Horrors it [__] forgot about
it
I'd forget about it too if that happened
to me
yeah
Jonathan said what if someone goes in
with a sports injury they may be shocked
see that's what I'm kind of wondering I
mean I'm sure if you were operating in
an illicit business like that I would
imagine that you would have to have like
a cover of like a legitimate business so
somebody just came in cluelessly and was
just like hey I tore my rotator cuff or
whatever
it's like they need like actual legit
massage stuff like people would do that
but it's like you kind of know the type
of person that comes in like kind of
looking Shifty and whatnot and like
you're like oh this person looks like
they want the special services yeah I
would think
I don't know I don't run around yeah
that girl that was doing that did did it
two different ways yeah because we know
we're not gonna say we're not We're not
gonna say what her name is but we know
this girl you would never suspect her
yeah she's definitely someone you would
never ever suspect of doing something
she looks kind of like uh but she works
she worked out of a massage parlor yeah
she had well that was the massage
problem
yeah yeah she worked out of a spa
she ran into like one of the rooms
inside of a spa
I think she might have been some kind of
massage therapist
and what she would do is she would run I
think back in those days as a back page
ad or my back page I think is what it
was yeah yeah she's running ads
about
it's real euphemistic right you know
what I mean
come see me at this place this location
ask for this ask for me
and [__] you know give you a great
[__] rub down [__] you'll be very
happy in the end you know that kind of
[__]
you'll be very happy yeah yeah
that was one way she would do it
and she got addicted to the money
and uh
she didn't start there though she
started in a massage parlor yeah and
those girls there taught her how to do
it
she was broke at the time and then she
made a lot of money quickly and that
place got busted so she [__] ran like
she got out of there never went back
yeah it was like an action scene she had
to like Escape like the cops came in the
front he left the shoes in there and
everything
she's actually really adorable so when I
found out when she told me my [__]
[__] job
well
so then she
uh she gets another job at a more
reputable place downtown
and used what she learned from the other
girls
um
her [__] ad techniques and she's and
I think it was back
yeah
and she put euphemistic ads there well
these dudes that [__] come up and
[__] ask for yeah and uh they knew
the [__] little code words and [__]
so she knew where that customer had come
from right
she jerked the dude off well eventually
one of those dudes talked her into
[__] full service
you [__] her
so she started off and she said I wasn't
that bad so she started offering that
yeah that went on for a while I can't
imagine yeah when she did that she she
started doing Backpage ads where she
would
rent a a motel
and hire security
and then [__] run the ad to that
motel room online
and I guess do [__] dozens of dudes
and it's like she said that was she said
that was like a windfall
she's making several thousand a night
many thousands a night
her prices weren't High either she was
only like 300.
but if you looked at her in the escort
World she'd be about an eighteen hundred
dollar a day escort that's what quality
she undersold herself quite a bit she
wasn't a drug addict
normal
well that was I think that was one of
the things better it's like she wasn't
she wasn't getting money for drugs she
was getting money just because she
wanted money she was actually getting
money well I don't I don't know if I
should say yeah I don't say it it was it
was to fuel another business yeah in the
entertainment business yeah and like not
uh nothing to do yeah right yeah and um
she was intelligent
good looking and and like
middle class to upper middle class
you would never suspect her I
she was like
kind of like a cross between a preppy
and a hippie kind of
type yeah
and um
totally uh
naive totally naive
she cried to me I can't understand why I
can't get a boyfriend and this is what
we thought well they don't agree with
what I do I was like what you tell them
it's like yeah don't tell them you're a
hooker
is that a problem because you [__]
idiot
tell anybody
she thought that because she was young
yeah and she just thought that was
normal
I guess to her it was I don't know
like I said
oh that's why they treat me that way
yeah
[Laughter]
yeah after after you tell them that they
treat like a horror [__] dump you
yeah yeah of course
yeah I mean
well I mean I hate to tell you but
that's how people are gonna appreciate
you yeah and that's I'm not saying
that's correct I'm not saying that's
good that's just life but that's the way
people are gonna yeah that's like
and that's the thing like and I don't
you know I wouldn't want to do it hmm
that's for sure
so in a way I almost I don't I don't
necessarily want to call it admiration
but I am kind of like well okay you do
you no most women that are in there
desperation that's what I mean but
people that actually do want to do it
are just like yeah [__] it I'll just do
it for the money like okay but yeah if
you just do it because it's like that's
the only thing so yeah that's shitty
like because that's kind of like you
don't really want to do it but you just
kind of have to so my friend in the
adult industry knows that industry too
and knows where they all come from and
how they get into porn and how they get
into streaming and only fans and all the
other [__] and the tears of depravity
how it happens
depravity that seems like it should be a
title yeah yeah yeah write a whole book
about it yeah I should yeah
yeah no
usually it's always homelessness and
drug addiction that's exactly what it is
they don't have a home they don't have a
family like I said they don't really
have a lot of options they don't have
any options they can't kind of get
kicked out and uh they start off couch
surfing
um in drug houses drug addict houses you
know just kind of Surfing from one couch
to the next they're kind of just party
girls having sex in order to get the
drugs
that they want
and then they realize they could
monetize it next thing you know they're
[__] out outside the drug house
selling it yeah on the street to get
money to bring in well because it's
going to be like well once you've done
that it's like well you might as well
just go to the next step right so then
somebody sees them out on the streets
and goes man you're just giving this
[__] away for free come on novel show
you how to do this right and then they
pick them up and clean them up and turn
them into an escort or a porn star
so that's the weird thing that I wanted
to tell you guys early I don't recommend
porn at all [__] me even though me
and Jen have done Pro-Am stuff
no and it's for young people this is not
very healthy and for a lot of times porn
is a step up for these girls
yeah not a step down step up
for the real at least there's some kind
of like regulation oversight yeah you
know right because before that a lot of
them were just [__] couch surfing
between off a drug through drug houses
or Street walking
at a pretty young age you know late
teens
so they're dumb to begin with
you know
so some of them it's uh porn is big move
up for them but they never stop
as soon as you as soon as a woman gets
involved in prostitution realize how
easy it is to make money like that which
is when she's young and good looking
they just can't resist the temptation so
even though they're in porn they're
doing
sugar in or they're escorting because a
lot of times the porn is just a
advertisement for the escort service
yeah a lot of times so but and if you do
it for long enough you're gonna have to
you're kind of gonna be stuck doing it
for
whatever because no one's ever really
gonna let you do anything else that's a
wrap you know what I mean yeah you're
gonna be still I mean there's still like
I said a bigger adult industry your
whole life
basically you'll get married but you'll
get married to a dude in adult industry
and he's probably not one of the Stars
he's probably one of the guys behind the
cameras and if you see what those guys
look like you but you know
but at least they have something in
common like they know like you're all on
the same page you know what I mean
yeah and they don't take it personally
for them this is just an activity and
They Don't Really Care
it's like being in the carnival now
they're not all like this but that's
kind of
traditionally they were like that
um that's not the same deal as say like
some
girl doing only fans from her bedroom
you know that's a totally different yeah
that's what I mean that's kind of like a
different yeah it's a whole different
Dynamic really
it's just like in pro wrestling there's
good girls and bad girls and good guys
and bad guys some of those girls are
good girls they're just working from
home
with a camera the only thing to have is
a hot body
they know how to run an account and they
know how to run [__] Twitter
and they uh take videos of themselves
doing solo scenes and can do pretty well
some of them can make six figures
you know for an 18 19 20 year old girl
it's a lot of money
let's see if she kind of comes from
nothing
um
but then again
they're doing their [__] on only fans
and the world's never really been like
this you got girls that are like that
they're good girls they gotta only fans
she's got gigantic boobs and [__]
cute
well guess what she has access to
celebrities celebrities are seeing those
and talking to her or dudes over in
Dubai you know flying her up for the
weekend and [__]
so the dating scene is real hard
for guys in their 20s and 30s right now
because the the best of the [__] poor
girls are getting sucked up
through the internet by dudes in other
countries used to be a good looking girl
would be the best looking girl in the
town and only that town would know about
her
now she's on the internet [__]
celebrities see her and [__] grab her
or sports figure
yeah he throws her away but he's done
with her but well that's par for the
course yeah because but I mean it's just
kind of like yeah I think it's kind of
like unprecedented in history that you
know you could conceivably just do
something in your living room yeah that
ends up being seen by like millions of
people like people from like across the
world like millions of people are seeing
it and thousands of them are [__]
and a few celebrities and guys who have
a lot of money
in other countries they're gonna go hey
you know what I want you come up I'll
fly you up for the weekend
you know this is where I live
they say yeah
so they do that
next thing you know they're escort
because that's what escorting is
you know and escorting is [__] it's
the same thing
it's just a more polite way of putting
it it's a different way of getting hold
of that problem it's just more expensive
more expensive more expensive and it's a
girlfriend type experience but that's
not a girlfriend that's an escort
a real expensive escort the prices
aren't even discussed if you got to
[__] talk about the price you can't
afford it
and according to uh my friend bill
about 70 of those escorts are Fool's
Gold
they're not worth the money laughs
I'm kind of scam Fool's Gold like the
like of the Elvis sandwich no it looks
like gold but it's not duh I know that I
was making a joke about the sandwich you
know it looks she looks like she'd be a
lot of fun but no good in bed or you
know
other problems or
you know
I mean if you had to [__] pay or this
money to come see you
know she's not really into you anyway
she's just there to take selfies on the
[__] front of your yacht
yeah I mean that's that's why I would
get not that I'd get her account topped
up yeah
I'm just gonna do the bare minimum she
can for you well you can't blame him
really it's just like look if people are
gonna pay like all that [__] money
and like fly you around and [__] like
that like take advantage and it's like
why why would you like strain yourself
if the dude's already paid and if you're
already there it's just kind of like oh
yeah you're awesome
whatever you don't have to like [__]
get to cc'd already paid you already
paid you don't got to make too much
effort I'm just saying
Tammy said or she gets sold into sex
labor in the black market yeah that is
also a large thing that happens
I've heard a lot of stories I don't know
how common this is at least well at
least in the United States I'm sure it's
common in other countries in terms of
who you are but the country you're
coming from
yeah I mean that I have heard stories
about people like uh little Rings like
of people
will kidnap you know teenage girls and
[__] like that and so but and I'm sure
it happens I just don't know how common
it is in the United States those girls
those guys that fly American girls up to
Dubai for the weekend they're not
they're not gonna sell that girl off
because she's not worth anything no that
wasn't what I was she's got he's got so
much money he's like what I'm gonna get
in all this trouble for ten thousand
dollars you know that dude can [__]
his his ten thousand dollar notes for
his toilet paper you know
which is crazy
um yeah they're talking about uh
Paul Flynn and murder Hornet are talking
about
uh anxiety and depression and murder
horn talk about all the drugs he did in
his younger days that gave him the
anxiety problems
I'm honestly I'm really glad that and I
don't have
um I'm not super judgy
about drugs
um you know as long as you can kind of
like keep your [__] under control and
everything like that I don't I don't
really have a problem with people doing
them
um but I will say that I'm glad that I
didn't ever get involved in that kind of
[__] and I didn't really know anybody
that got super involved in it I did know
a couple people that did but they're
just some of them you can't [__] with
yeah you just can't [__] with Heroin
right yeah you know you're just not
gonna really come back from that I've
never seen anybody's messing around with
that kind of walked away from it yeah
not really you're just kind of like too
habit-forming I mean people do survive
it obviously because there's a lot of
old rock stars they never quite kick
though right you know even Billy Idol
man come on
I wonder sometimes how much they like
want to go back to it
oh Rich Campbell my buddy you know he
was a junkie and
to the day he died until he blew his
head off
and he never really kicked it
he just would take little vacations
I've heard that
um you know people that people are
particularly into heroin it's like
they'll try to get off it but yeah never
really they usually just get sucked back
in like I said I don't really know I've
you know I've never done it so I don't
really know like what's so [__]
awesome about it the
well it's probably like a really good
form of like Demerol if you ever had
Demerol you ever had Demerol for like
having surgeries yeah once good it's
gonna be something like that probably a
lot better mixed with that opium I've
smoked opium before but they say that's
like nothing compared to heroin
and opium's nice you know
but very comfortable I probably put
opium on par with alcohol in terms of
its power
but its effects are a little different
it's just really chilling it would
really chill you out
you sit there all night do nothing and
be content
hmm
Paul Flint said had LSD eight times
don't do any now for years yeah I like
it it's good beer only yeah I mean
um yeah I always quite enjoyed it but
like I said I'm not a big drug person I
don't I don't really I've smoked pot a
few times but I don't I don't really
like it it makes me feel kind of
paranoid
and like other than that
that's about I mean that's about it Coke
wants
um didn't love that
uh
yeah it's just it's something that never
really appealed to me honestly I didn't
even start drinking until I was older
like not regularly you know like when I
was younger I would have them like every
now and then but it wasn't just because
it wasn't
um you know my family weren't drinkers
so we didn't usually have alcohol in the
house and it just wasn't it wasn't any
and it wasn't anything to do with kind
of like oh we don't have that stuff in
the house it's just like my parents were
just not really that into it like if
they were having people over or
something they'd get they'd get beers or
wine or something like that but they
didn't have any hard liquor in the house
so it's just wasn't something that was
you know kind of part of it growing up
so I had someone I was a teenager and
someone was in my 20s but it wasn't
really that big a deal so but I didn't
really start drinking even until I was
older
um let's see
uh yeah murder Hornet set out I've
noticed one night was going to a bad
party before I went I did crank pills
Coke and took LSD on the way there and
booze and more pills after three days
later I started having panic attacks
well that's not really a big surprise
honestly I don't even know
I've heard stories of like people that
when they were real young that did some
[__] like that like crazy stories I'm
just like how the [__] are you even
still walking around that's insane
John Smith said so has anyone else been
following the Lisk arrest I start I was
following it at first like when we were
doing the show about it but like last I
heard they were digging up some
or they were um looking into some Las
Vegas murders which I knew they were
going to find some [__] there yeah
that's where Excavating gonna be his
main hunting ground but I haven't been
following it since then as a Backpage
killer
Craigslist Ripper that was one of the
names for him actually I think
Craigslist is where she would actually
advertise a lot of that yeah they don't
Craigslist is still around but I don't
think people really use it anymore yeah
because well didn't they didn't they get
rid of the they got rid of the personal
stuff of the personal section yeah
because it was all
but there was I remember like back in
the day when people used to post [__] on
their legs they were all kind of weird
yeah
well they got
all it's not necessary anymore what it
was called like Babylon
and it goes [__] escort Babylon I
think is what it's called or Babylon
another one is [__]
tryst
trist.link I think is one of them and uh
so you don't need those anymore
that's a straight up escort
site platform
I still one of these days I want to
watch that documentary about Ashley
Madison
what's that about that's that site that
uh let's put it this way facilitated
um marital infidelity that was where
this is where if you were married you
can go and find like okay so we'll see I
don't know this but somebody made a
documentary about it like a couple years
ago and it sounded kind of interesting
and I kind of wanted to watch it but I
don't remember if it's on Netflix or I
don't remember where it is but yeah it
was supposed to be like a cheating
yeah that's exactly what it was
I had heard that it came out that most
of the female profiles on it were fake
well I think that's true of all of the
of a lot of those uh kind of sites yeah
because they're trying to get dudes to
sign up yeah
and women are generally not going I'm
not saying women won't sign up for that
but to a large degree women don't sign
up for that kind of [__] too rare yeah
so there are other ways yeah so they're
gonna have to like bulk it out with fake
profiles yeah and I think that was kind
of like but I don't know enough about I
read some articles about it back in the
day when there was like the big
controversy about how much the profiles
were fake and everything like that but
um I kind of wanted to watch the
documentary it was I think it's on
Netflix but I can't remember I think if
a woman wanted to cheat today she would
just
get them
um
what's what's the one that everybody
just uses uh I never used it uh uh most
common one tender Tinder they'll
probably just get a tender account and
not mention that you're married
well yeah I assume a lot of people and
baby just have photos of you on there
but they're slightly catfished slightly
tweaked so your husband doesn't
recognize you
probably that probably in case he's on
there yeah because you never know yeah
he might be on her and then you might
end up meeting each other just like the
[__] Pina Colada song yeah
yeah except that was in the 70s so that
was personal ads but they ended up they
were she trying to cheat on each other
and then they ended up answering their
each other's personal ads and they're
like oh we really were meant for each
other that's that's the whole plot of
that song in case you didn't know
but yeah that would be the modern day
version you put me on Tinder it ended up
matching with one another that would be
super funny
uh American Military 100 said I think
Ashton Madison got hacked and some
high-level Executives got busted one
dude killed himself after being outed
yeah I remember hearing some [__] about
that too because like they somebody
hacked into their database and like
leaked a bunch of names that were on
there and some of the people I don't
know if they're like famous or they were
kind of like high marketing muktek the
type of evil and some of these people
were like really upset at being I was
like well
maybe you should have been on there in
the first place if you were that worried
about it you know
just saying
um I saw someone uh oracle's here hey
y'all pour me something tall and strong
because I've had a hell of a week yeah
okay I mean this week has just seemed
really really long I don't know why
maybe it was because maybe it was
because well you were sick yeah and
I don't know
I'm just coming out of it now yeah
you do definitely seem a lot better but
you I don't think I mean you didn't
sleep for two days but almost almost see
I kind of slept for two straight days
pretty much but I told you you probably
needed to yeah
you know
um
oh [__] Oracle said remember how I said
a former teammate had been given six
months to live yeah you just said that
like the other day she died Tuesday
afternoon yeah oh [__] I'm really sorry
about that yeah remember you saying that
you just said that like the other day
like on Wednesday show or Monday show I
can't remember
holy [__]
cats in the litter box yeah
I had that litter box in there it's that
it's um
what's it called it's called The Breeze
system or something and it's got like
the big uh pellets and they're really
they're they're good like they're easier
to scoop and everything like that but
they're really loud so when she gets in
there she just like
by the way we decided
um you know our new little kitty Dakota
we need we're gonna keep that as her
official name because that's the name
she came from the shelter with and I'm
just like yeah she kind of looks like so
we'll just leave that as her official
name but I was like but she needs
another name because Pookie's name real
name is Baby Cookie that's just we don't
usually call her that we almost always
call her Pookie so I was just kind of
like well I think Dakota also needs a
nickname
that is more to do with her actual
personality but it took us a really long
time to come up with Pookie's name
because we wanted to like get to know
her first and everything like that
however yesterday was it yesterday last
night I think it was last night
and Dakota was over there chomping down
on uh uh a little dish of cat treats
that we have there in the bedroom and
that's cat can eat and she's skinny
she's like a little tiny skinny cat and
she eats like
uh
a lot like I can put out like little
two or three little like servings like
for the kitties and stuff like that and
she'll just come in and just eat all of
them like in [__] and I'm just like
those were not all for you but okay
but um but since she was there eating
and I noticed that her little butt looks
like because she's a Max too her tail
isn't as short as pookies is it's kind
of probably about half as long as a as a
standard cat tail
but it's cut so it's still kind of short
but it's like kind of Darker and like
tiger striped on the top side but then
on the underside it's kind of white
and then I said to Tom I was like you
know she kind of looks like a
white-tailed deer like from the back and
I said holy [__] we should call her
Bambi because not only because her tail
looks like because her butt looks like a
deer butt but also because she has super
long legs and she kind of Walks Like a
baby deer like you know what a baby deer
is just born and it's kind of like can't
really walk right yet she kind of Walks
Like That
like because she's always like trying to
get in really close to you and like rub
against your leg and everything but
she's kind of awkward because her legs
are so long and I was like that's
exactly what she looks like she looks
like a baby deer so that's what we're
gonna call her we're gonna call her baby
Jasmine says Dakota's nickname Tribble
that would be good too that would be
good too
but I kind of liked Bambi because it was
kind of like it's two syllables and also
ends with an e sound like Pookie does
you know what I mean
um
they're talking about uh drugs opiates
so yeah Paul Flynn is in the UK actually
Zach says the cat we got in Hawaii Simba
would eat and eat and eat when we
adopted him I haven't even seen a dog
eat that much yeah she's I don't know if
it's just because she's been in a
shelter for a long time and it's like
she didn't get enough food because there
was a lot of other cats around but you
can't like legit the second you put any
food down anywhere she eats all of it
she just pops out and eats all of it
yeah and I'm like God damn
because I told it's like I usually I'll
get up and I'll put like a couple
different flavors of food out like you
know hoping that Pookie will eat some
too but it's like by the time Pookie
gets in there
the other cats are she's already eating
it all she just goes from plate to Plate
just like God damn she's like a little
Pac-Man
Oracle says my husband's dog was
officially named Chocolate but his
nickname was Mr fuzz
his other nickname was dummy dog
yeah with that's the thing like we call
Pookie mostly Pookie or variations of
Pokey
but I have other I call her other things
too we have other names that we call her
I call her little or muffin or
things like that
count pukula I call her that sometimes
too
Ryan says has anyone seen the deleted
scene from Poltergeist that was just
uploaded to Instagram today I have not
what was it
like is it one that had been shown
before or was this like the first time
that um that anyone had ever seen it
because
I didn't even hear about that now I'm
gonna have to go check it out
so you're feeling better Tom yeah a
little bit better
oh [__] Oracle said
he was apparently a dog of very little
brain oh but he was a sweetie though he
was also little he almost got carried
off by an owl once
man that used to make me so paranoid
back when we lived at the old house
when Pookie used to want to go outside
and like go around the porch
and in the backyard I was always like
terrified that like a [__] owl was
gonna come and take her when she was
little
we always had to go out there and like
stand with her
well and remember when we not too long
after we moved here
um Beijing was outside because she goes
and sits out on the back porch sometimes
Pookie doesn't want to go outside
anymore which is fine with me because
she's afraid of the dogs next door
but um
Beijing went outside and we were in the
house and we heard
like a blood curdling
sound that sounded like a cat being
horribly murdered
and we were like what the [__] and like
we went out there and like ran around
and looked and we couldn't find Beijing
and we were like flipping out and then
we waited and waited it's just it was
getting later and later and later in the
night and I was like oh my God that was
her like something got her and we were
like flipping out about it but then like
it was then like 10 11 o'clock at night
it was late right it was like probably
like 11 11 30 something like that all of
a sudden Beijing just pops up and it's
like looking in the sliding glass door
like hey open the door and I'm just like
what the [__] so we never did find out
like what that noise was though but we
were for sure it was her because she
almost always comes back but then we
forgot about that one yeah we heard that
horrible noise and then she didn't come
back for hours and hours and then she
was all [__] casual when she came
back she's like hey
here I am let me back in the house
please
but holy crap
uh American Military 100 Jenny and Tom
what was your reaction to William
freaking's death side question do you
think his 1982 film cruising was
overrated I don't think I'd say it was
overrated I actually hadn't seen it
um for many years I don't even know who
that is and that William freaking he the
actual he directed The Exorcist okay
among other things yeah I just don't
know if that is really he never seen
that movie but yeah you've seen some and
he did uh he also did the Ninth
Configuration which we reviewed that was
a weird ass movie
but um yeah it was a it was a bummer I'm
telling you it's a bummer but um
cruising I don't know I really like that
movie
I've never seen it you might like it
what's it about it's kind of like the
kind of gay underground in the 70s like
bath houses and stuff like that
it's you know Zachary's Jam Zach's jam
and he did the French Connection that's
right I forgot about that he's done a
[__] ton of movies like probably the
exorcism or although I don't know French
connections maybe his most famous one
but the X just is the one that I'm most
familiar with but
yeah he's one what was the other one
that he did
so I just I remember Ninth Configuration
because I remember we reviewed that like
last year
and what a weird ass movie that was but
he's done like a bunch of other ones too
but I just can't remember I thought I
did a review of cruising but maybe not
because I remember watching it not too
long ago
Ryan said let's talk about the
Poltergeist deleted scene it was the
very first time anyone had seen it the
deleted scene is where Beach or straight
takes the jewelry that fell from the
ceiling of the house and finds out some
creepy information about them
oh [__] I didn't even know that that was
I don't remember jewelry falling from us
yeah yeah because remember they had the
in Poltergeist they have the portal oh
Poltergeist yeah that comes through the
all the [__] comes through the thing and
they had you know they did the tennis
balls through there and everything I was
thinking The Exorcist and it had goop
all over it yeah and then they had all
that jewelry come down and yeah you're
right it's like they never did really
explain like what that was or where that
came from
evidently what
water that people
that people real dead bodies and they
didn't tell the people well I've heard
that but I don't know if that's an urban
legend or not I think they said it was I
mean they said they had some cadavers
that they used it's like yeah but let's
just throw them there in the Mud Pot a
little probably be fine no one will get
a disease or anything I'm sure it was
like a legally purchased cadavers but
yeah definitely they had some of that
water yeah
I've heard that as well because it had
been from aldehyde
yeah it's not that it's not like they
just went like Ed Gein and like dug up
some [__] and threw it in there
I think they did have some cadavers that
they kind of and they kind of like put
stuff on them like dress them up
together they would look more closer
you know but yeah I have heard that but
like I said I don't know if that's true
there's a lot of stories about
wasn't I kind of feel like there's a
there's a um Poltergeist again I haven't
seen that in a long time that's what I
was thinking it's like I love that movie
I've seen it a million times I probably
haven't memorized
we should I don't you know what have we
reviewed it for the show
we probably haven't even if we have it's
like who gives a [__] maybe we can watch
it after the after the live stream
if somebody's got it I don't know if
it's probably streaming somewhere
but that well
there's a I think there's there's a um
series on shutter
called cursed films
and I'm pretty sure there was an episode
about Poltergeist I could be wrong about
it
I remember they had one about the
Exorcist and they had because all kind
of crazy [__] happened on the
background of the background of that
like behind the scenes of that
especially I remember like um
because remember that um in The Exorcist
when they had um
Linda Blair and she's in the bed and
they had that uh
that uh what do they call it that
harness thing like when she was going
like that in the bed yeah and it's like
she got all [__] up like an injured
because of that and also Ellen burstin
when um she gets thrown across the room
yeah like in the dresser she um
I don't think she broke her back but she
got like she [__] her back all up like
when they did that like she really did
get hurt when they were doing that
what does everybody think about the new
Exorcist movie that's coming out that
does have Ellen Burston in it we keep
seeing the trailer like when we go to
the movies and none right no that's the
kind that's the conjuring okay
remember we saw the first nun oh yeah in
the theater and then we saw yeah okay
there's a new extra
yeah yeah yeah and people keep saying
it's a reboot it's not a reboot it looks
like a sequel yeah yeah because Alan
Burson is in it she's like oh yeah the
same thing happened to my daughter so
I'm gonna help you guys out so it's
obviously a seasonal
it might you know what it's it looks
like from the trailer I was like that
could either be pretty awesome or really
really stupid I can't really decide it
seemed like it was gonna be good which
way it's gonna go it could go either way
it's hard to tell from a trailer because
a lot of times the trailer they're not
really
the the the quibble that I have
with the Exorcist trailer is they seem
like they're giving the whole [__] away
but maybe it's just kind of like there's
gonna be more to it than that bro well
yeah so maybe that's what they're doing
but I mean I kind of feel like well
everybody knows the Exorcist So it's not
like they're gonna surprise anybody you
know what I mean I was doing some
research on Mad Max the Mad Max universe
there's a new uh there's a there's a new
YouTube channel
I'll let uh
there's a new Mad Max Channel on YouTube
it's
it's and I'd always wondered you know I
always thought that Fury Road was just
kind of like a like a reboot just
another legendary Tale
but no they uh were they started to work
on that way back in the 90s and it was
going to have Mel Gibson in it
and it's it's it's Mad Max 4.
uh it's just that by the time they were
ready to do it
because [__] got postponed because of
the war and
[__] happened with Mel Gibson probably
because remember remember when Mel gets
them blew up
yeah he didn't literally blow up yeah
Bill gets to get drunk and [__] talk
his teeth [__] [__] talk
crazy all right I like Gibson
racist when he's drunk
he didn't like the Jews man yeah
he didn't like them at all I mean and uh
he he was [__] cussing them out but I
don't I think it's mostly mad at his
wife
I don't know how much it was
so I've been mad at a lot of people but
I didn't impugn an entire race he
sounded drunk he sounded drunk he
sounded drunk up his ass even when I was
drunk I've never done that so I'm just
I'm just gonna say if you do do that
you're probably kind of a shitty person
even when you're sober so
ah anyway that's really no excuse me
yes it was [__] hammered out of his
[__] cord
I think he was [__] pissed off and
anyway
because his [__] blew up they couldn't
put him in Mad Max they're like yeah
let's not put him in there so they put
so they put uh Tom Hardy in there later
on and uh and you know actually we love
Tom Hardy yeah so that's actually even
though like he's way too young for it to
be part four who cares because he just
said [__] it the [__] it originally it
was gonna be like a it was gonna be
Mel Gibson in his 50s
and uh which which the timeline makes a
lot more sense
and
but I was thinking you know what what
about that car though he had the
Interceptor the Interceptor got
destroyed already what the [__] is
and the explanation was in the original
script
that Max was
so obsessed about that model of car that
he would lose it a lot but would rebuild
that same mod XP Falcon with the gas
tanks in the back and [__]
Max would rebuild that car over and over
again so it wasn't the same car it was
just a the same model but I was just
saying that even if I mean we've talked
about this before we maybe talked about
this when we were talking about Fury
Road
which is a [__] awesome movie by the
way yeah that's great but the thing
about the Mad Max movies is that I
always kind of thought of them less as
like a progression like as in a movie in
a sequel and bloody blah as more like a
collection of stories about a particular
character yeah you know what I mean yeah
they're kind of like being told to you
right I kind of like took them so it
doesn't really matter if like a
different person plays him or if like if
the timeline is not doesn't line up or
something like that these are just kind
of like folk tales I always kind of see
it like it's being told a folk tale
about like a legend like a legendary guy
it was right kind of a Christ metaphor
yeah that's kind of how I don't know
he's a savior of the Wasteland right so
I didn't worry too much about there was
a lot of cool [__] that was taken out
taken out of all those movies
watching that the one of the best
[__] ideas the bet they should have
never done it
if you guys remember Mad Max Road
Warrior Two
um the humongous you know the
the bald guy who's all burnt up
you know Warrior of the Wasteland all
that guy you know
it was supposed to be later on
um
humongous was would recognize Max
and unveil himself as he was actually
the goose
who was mad Max's best friend from the
first story from the first one who got
burned up
remember the last time you see me was
still in the hospital was just burnt up
Max went crazy he says no that's not him
that's not the goose they went back and
he takes Vengeance out on toe Cutters
gang
but that was a great idea but they
should have never taken that up but they
thought that people wouldn't hadn't seen
the first movie
but they should have done it anyway
yeah it's like who [__] cares don't
worry about like if yeah I'm always a
big advocate of
um what I call the mst3k principle where
they're like we didn't worry about if
nobody was gonna get these jokes but us
we just thought they were funny so we
put them in there pretty much it's like
somebody out there will get it so it's
fine but there was gonna be a badass
scene where
the humongous recognizes Max and then
tells him who he is and he's all the you
know it's kind of like the Darth Vader
scene like no I'm your father he's gonna
be like that kind of [__] and he goes no
man I'm the goose and he was going to
try to get him to [__] join
the Roadkill
a roadkill crew what was the name of
that [__]
humongous Army I forgot what they were
called maybe maybe they weren't called
anything
but you're trying to get them to
Warriors of the Wasteland or something
just trying to get them to join his gang
and uh boy she's there making noise
again how many times I the thing is I
don't think she's I don't scoop that
much
[Laughter]
because like really I only skip poop out
of there like in the morning and at
night that's it's only two times
they need to give the Mad Max property
to me I'll fix that [__]
they got a lot of guys who got really
talented
I don't think there's gonna be any more
of them but there was supposed to be a
furiosa movie and everything see I would
watch that because Julius is badass
Ryan says I want to see the next
Exorcist bringing back Ellen Burston is
like for me when they brought back the
original Karate Kid characters in the
Cobra Kai show yeah I guess so and if
you're if you're new here we love
[__] Cobra Kai we always watch it
like as soon as the new season drops we
totally watch that [__] it was supposed
to be a furio so backstory yeah uh
prequel
it was it wasn't a sequel yeah well that
makes sense because you where she came
from right how she became pray to her
how she lost her hand and all that how
she [__] left the I guess what they
called the the Kundalini no the um
what are they called Volvo lady
volvalini like a like a like a like a
vulva is that skeptical yeah I thought
that's what that was okay
no that's that love and Rocket song
Kundalini Express
Brian says what do you think Jaws would
be like if it was a Lucio fulchi film
well well for sure it would have his
like Sharktopus no I no what I was gonna
say if you knew anything about Lucio
volci movies I was gonna say well it
would for sure have a zombie in it
punching the shark so
because yeah zombie has
a shark versus zombie scene it's pretty
Epic hahaha Oracle said I figure Max was
kind of like Robin Hood plenty of
stories Consolidated around one man but
there may have been several yeah that
was kind of the spirit that I took it
into
I mean I don't really get to
as far as movies are concerned or any
kind of like
you know Media or artwork are concerned
I don't get too upset about
you know I'm not going to sit there and
like get all pedantic about this and
that and the other I do about some
things but not usually about that kind
of thing they showed all the drawings of
all the cars the characters Nooks slit
and everything from Fury Road when they
were working on them in the early 90s
and they were [__] really close
I mean they nailed it
it didn't change much from the original
idea in the original script the drawings
are really cool look like something kind
of at a Tank Girl
and uh
the war boys weren't called the war boys
they were called the necro boys what
they were called originally War boys is
better yeah War boys but they're called
the necro boys originally and they had
um painted or uh tattooed on their face
huge shark teeth and huge mouths uh was
part of their
huge more huge miles with like Jagged
teeth they got the idea from like uh
P-47 tomahawks from [__] the Flying
Tigers
uh mercenary Air Group and defended
China for a while I don't know if you
guys know but that's where they got the
idea of they looked really cool in the
drawings
yeah
Ryan says thoughts on I saw the devil
that is actually probably my favorite
Korean film of all time
uh if you haven't yeah because remember
I kept telling you because I saw it a
long time ago and I was like oh my God
this was like one of the best movies
ever for sure like one of the best
revenge movies and it's pretty [__] up
there's like it's pretty violent and
pretty disturbing so it's like for a
long time I kept telling us like you got
to see this movie you gotta see this
because he likes Korean movies yeah so
finally I got him to watch oh yeah yeah
yeah it was the guy remember it was like
the guy that was he was like a um like a
um police investigator and his wife got
murdered and dismembered by a serial
killer and then he goes and goes after
the serial killer but he keeps like
[__] him up and then like letting him
go so they can do like a cat and mouse
kind of thing oh it's so good it's so
good and like I said it's like it's
super super violent like don't watch it
if you're squeamish for sure but um
because some pretty [__] up [__]
happens in it but there's another going
it's called old boy yeah like if you
liked old boy you would definitely like
I saw the devil yeah a guy ends up he
gets it gets abducted and put into a
private prison and it's just a private
prison run by I guess that gets a gang
and you're just in this room old boy is
great yeah
window and hey people they feed the same
[__] yakimandu every day which is pot
stickers oh we can get some pot stickers
tomorrow I was gonna say tomorrow it's
really good we're like so we become such
creatures of habit it's like every day
we're just kind of like are we going to
the yeah I'm gonna go to Chinese
well it's good because there's like I
kind of like you know there's a bunch of
stuff there so you can just kind of have
whatever eat the same thing every day
every time I go I got it down I got it
down with science
yeah sometimes they have because I think
last time we went we went actually after
we saw the movie because we got there
too late so we had the dinner thing so
they didn't have some of the stuff that
worked out though it worked out yeah
yeah it actually did work out better
because we didn't have to rush yeah well
I usually go I can't eat that much
anymore so I have to kind of
plan out yeah rainbow sherbert and all
the [__] ice cream [__] Tom's
gonna be all here yeah it was the green
and red and orange and orange I try not
to eat too much dessert but they do have
these really nice like kind of
shortbread almond cookies that I'm into
so I usually get one of those but then I
usually just get one we gotta make a
video
but those pot stickers also known as
[__] dumplings you know the deep
fried their dumplings are really good I
feel like their dumplings are better
than what I want they're the koi wants
dumplings man and they they have the
damn uh sauce which is it's kind of like
a Teriyaki kinda I don't know
it's kind of like a
soy sauce with probably like wine and a
little bit of sugar in it or something
that [__] is [__] good they had them
in Korea they were just like that
more or less
and uh man I'll eat like [__] eight
of those things yeah he'll come back
just with one plate with just a big pile
of those
I'll get a big plate of
cold boiled shrimp cocktail sauce
I punish them for putting shrimp well
like I said I can't eat as much and
every time I've noticed that every
subsequent time we go I've been able to
eat less and less
so it's like so I really have to pick
out and I want like a little bit of each
thing so I try to like
just have like a little bit of each
thing I try to concentrate on Seafood
because I really like seafood and we
don't make it much at home and I try to
like get a lot of vegetables no carbs I
try to do no carbs yeah like no one is
talking about crab rangoons they got
them they got those they got those but
those men those things are really high
carbohydrates calories
and um they're never fresh really
they're never really hot enough they're
just sitting on a steam table it's
always kind of like slightly cold so I
don't really [__] with them not worth
the calories
everything that's so easy to make man
yeah you can wrap her down at the
[__] grocery store
they're in the produce section usually
and uh it's just
can't
crab meat
a little bit of garlic add sour cream
that's it not sour cream cream cheese
you mix it up in a bowl first with
chives
you put that in the middle of one of
those each one of those wonton wrappers
and you glue them a little bit of water
water and flour paste you make deep fry
them they're much better when they're
fresh
well yeah that's true eat it with
mustard yeah
the ones you get at the at the buffet
yeah they're good but they're never
they're never quite good as fresh even
when they just first bring them out they
seem to like cool off really quick I
don't usually I like them but I don't
usually have something that can sit
around for very long because I feel like
because there's so much other stuff yeah
that I could be eating then it's like
well it seems like a waste of eat four
of those calories
oh easily yeah maybe more
[Laughter]
and that's don't get me wrong I [__]
love cream cheese I'll eat a whole block
of cream cheese going after another
plate of [__] another plate of
[__] shrimp boiled shrimp
they had fried shrimp flattened out
butterflied yeah I didn't even get I was
gonna go back and get some more of that
but I was too full yeah they had and
they had oysters too which they don't
usually have on the lunch buffet fried
oysters they were they fried I'm asking
you they had raw ones I didn't they
maybe had fried ones on the other side
but yeah they had some different [__]
out like on the dinner thing dinner it
was after yeah it was after 3 P.M or
after 4 P.M or whatever because normally
we go like you go in there in the
afternoon on a Saturday it's nothing but
fat people every time just fat people
and the wind staff
they're all fat retired people
yeah it's pretty extraordinary well like
I said the the area that we live in yeah
is kind is pretty rural
and it's kind of like a lot of retirees
especially like right around that mall
around that mall is kind of like there's
a lot of trailer parks like not like
seasonal like mobile home parks yeah
like they're nicer they're not like
super trashy or anything
some of them are trashy but like some of
them are kind of nice and then there's
like right down the street there's kind
of like nicer like gated community type
things
so there's a lot of retirees yeah
retirees from out of state I mean I get
like if you have a big family or
something like that I guess that's like
a good deal because you you can take
your kids there and they can just eat as
much as they want and like you don't
have to feed them the rest of the day so
in that way it's kind of um
cost effective
but
like I said every every subsequent time
we go I just find myself eating yeah
less and less just because I can't well
you're not eating this much
yeah I just I can't get as much down
like yeah I've heard they got Mongolian
beef there it's good man
they got that also yeah yeah they got it
I put a [__] uh chili oil on it
make it even hotter
I can't I can't do hot food anymore
you know getting too old for them
but he's saying I love balls in my back
what are you talking about man
making [__] up
yeah he does love balls in his mouth
Oracle said I'm gonna try making naan
tomorrow oh yeah it's not hard none we
made it before huh yeah it's not hard
you wanna if the the best way to make
knot is if you have a pizza stone
get that pizza stone really hot like 500
fees maximum heat high up on your um
oven rack and place the Naan in there
I'm using a pizza peel which is a big
flat thing you used to
you can just pull the rack out toss it
on there
try to make it hit so it's round
and that
that hot stone the induction will
[__] cook that just right then close
it and shut it for a few seconds and
then flip it over
do it a little bit more and then pull it
out
because you don't have a Tandoor oven
see yeah which is a big [__] clay pot
with a bunch of hot coals in it sitting
in a bunch of hot coals you put they're
putting that chip I mean I think it's
just coals around it ideally that's what
you're supposed to have yeah and you're
throwing the bread on the inside of that
damn pot big Tandoori pot and I'm
pulling it off pulling it out of there
but the pizza Stone's close similar
well naan's good because I mean
we used to just make pizzas on that if
you were too if we were too lazy to get
it pre-made and freeze it it keeps
forever yeah we used to go to the Indian
market and get like they have this big
[__] things of it and we used to use
that [__] for everything yeah and made
sandwiches with it sandwiches Pizza
whatever like breakfast sandwiches like
just put some eggs and [__] on it yeah
[Laughter]
kind of like a panini but like you know
what I mean it's just pretty easy to
make it's just
flour
and then um
it was water and I think some yogurt in
the water
and I think a little bit of sugar
it's got to sit there and it
then you add the flour to it and it
turns into the dough
but you got it it's got to sit in there
and kind of ferment for a little while
I don't remember exactly how I did it
just got to look it up I don't remember
any of those recipes by uh by you know
remember I don't have them memorized you
got to go in there and read them
murder Hornet said I had a Filipino
girlfriend she wanted me to try balut
I'm like hell no pretty much yeah yeah
I've seen that I'm like why would anyone
ever put that in their mouth like other
than on a dare and like not even then
some of that weird
Asian Cuisine
they have like in Thailand and
China where they're eating roaches and
bugs and [__] like that that's not their
normal cuisine
that happened when they when they got
really poor under the under communist
regimes that [__] up their damn food
production and famines a hit then they
they resort to eating bugs
they try to dress them up with the
seasonings that they use but if you talk
to any Thai Chef they didn't eat water
bugs and [__] that was that's modern
that was after [__] that was that
happened during some kind of communist
[__] famine that they had for a while
they got rid of those governments like
you guys don't have to eat them you
don't have to eat bugs anymore you've
got KFC now yeah that's why you got the
dub the world economic Forum saying that
you're gonna eat bugs and live in a pod
and eat [__] what they call them they
even had that little [__] Tom
Cruise's ex-wife out there [__]
trying to eat bugs and tell you how good
they're not gonna eat bugs they're gonna
eat [__] flaming young they're trying
to get poor people to eat bugs they want
as many poor people as they can because
it's easier to control poor people
especially if they're miseducated and
real religious
they think they're saving the Earth and
keeping it from catching on fire and
[__] carbon Footprints and [__] you
can tell anybody anything and get them
to become subservient you know whatever
they think it may be true I don't know
if you fall for that you deserve it
but I ain't eating bugs I'd rather eat
them before I eat a bug
I [__] I'm I like I'm like my
Islander boys that I talk to online
[__]
coming up out of the army [__]
Micronesia and
fijians and [__]
you Vanquish an enemy you eat him you
know won't let that protein go to waste
man you want to absorb his natural
[__] masculine power see just like
old [__] what's his name uh Hannibal
Lecter
he knew the deal
yeah
you killed my cat I'mma eat you
well I would probably eat you if you did
that just to spite you yeah you try to
starve me I'm gonna eat you
Victor said I need a dude
I mean
you'd have to do something really really
bad to me
but if you came in here and like tried
to do some really bad [__] I would
probably I would probably eat you just
and I would eat you this so you would
know that I was eating you like a little
bit at a time so I could crap you out
and flush it down a [__] toilet throw
it away with the rest of this [__] right
that's what I'm saying yeah I got
stronger you got weaker you became [__]
like I don't I don't believe in any of
that getting their essence or anything
like that that's that's why it's so
important that you'd have to do it a
little bit at a time
because they'd have to know that you
were cutting off pieces of them and it's
like hey I'm gonna go [__] out part of
you now be back in a minute you know
what I mean to be that kind of thing
maybe they'd like something out of that
movie Quest for Fire remember that with
a [__] [__] caveman I haven't seen
that in a long time man they used to
[__] play they used to play that on
[__] cable we didn't rent that one
too I'd like to see question fire again
so we're gonna see Poltergeist and Quest
for Fire Ray dong Chong her naked ass
running around through half a day well
you know that's why everybody watched
that movie back
caveman didn't wear clothes come on
we're gonna see all the naked ladies but
uh they found I think if I remember
correctly they found radar Chong tied to
a tree and all her friends were [__]
had their arms and legs eaten off and
remember the big old fat redheaded dudes
are eating them I haven't seen that in a
long time yeah I saw it a bunch of times
on cable one time and then they had to
talk good guys [__] saved or [__]
cut her cut the [__] ropes and pulled
her off a tree
saved her from getting eaten yeah raid
on Chong was hot she was hot actually
yeah she's cute I haven't seen her in a
long time but
she was too skinny to be hot I
remembered her from I mean she was in a
bunch of stuff but I for some reason I
remember her a lot from that terrible
movie that was on MST which was called
City Limits that also had Robbie Benson
in it yeah and the dude from
Christine and Real Genius yeah what was
that guy's name John Stockwell maybe
Robbie Benson
yeah yeah he was from [__] um
[__] uh
oh and Billy Joe right
it's been a long time since I've seen
that too
you know who else was in city limits was
um
uh
Darth Vader's voice
yeah
there you go thank you but I don't know
why I couldn't remember that so yeah
then look man
James
all just African and Irish descent
his parents were
Scholars they worked in a university
and he was a [__] Army Ranger a lot
of people don't know that
that chambers of Jones was the Army
Ranger he was
an officer too
so when you see Darth Vader the for the
voice of Darth Vader
is a biracial
Ranger from [__] Mississippi just
keep that in mind all right that that's
that's the voice of Darth Vader
and rightly so
I mean sure [__] right it was a false
of Doom man my favorite movie of all
time [__] Conan
it's like a James Earl Jones knocked it
out of the [__] part wigging all yeah
I'm gonna say I'm gonna say the wig was
good too all right well if anybody could
pull off that wig yeah it would be James
okay bangs and everything nobody else
could pull off bangs like James Earl
Jones that's for sure it made sense if
you understand the script he was a
[__] 4 000 year old [__] Atlantean
[__] uh sorcerer
okay
so of course he's gonna have hair like
that yeah he's gonna be a ancient race
of people that don't exist anymore
they're just kind of mixture of
everything kind of white and black and
Oriental and [__] long straight hair
and bangs and can talk him his way into
power and just a cult leader you know
his his version of sorcery was to get
you to just give yourself up into this
damn
Cult of cannibals
okay I got like a lot of stuff I gotta
answer okay Victor said I heard the guy
that played Darth Vader didn't know he
was getting dubbed until he watched the
movie yeah I've heard that too that was
like a problem David prowse David browse
that's right and um who was also the big
guy in A Clockwork Orange the body art
The Bodyguard yeah he was in a lot of
other movies he was in a lot of movies
yeah but bodybuilder yeah yeah
but that's yeah I I heard that too that
it's like he didn't know
Ryan he had a strong accent yeah you
weren't going to be able to
and his voice wouldn't work for Darth
Vader man [__] James Earl Jones the
voice but yeah I mean you know I can't
imagine we see that character
um
the script called for a a a dark ominous
voice
and evidently the people in casting
said well let's try a black guy and then
James Earl Jones and he had that voice
they said yeah that's it well I mean
they needed somebody that sounded like
creepy right and and [__]
Jones was [__] great he was a great
actor man he was really good in [__]
um
one about the nuclear Annihilation uh
[__] uh
how I learned to love the bomb
what was the name of that doctor strange
Dr Strangelove
yeah he played one of the [__]
crewmen in the B-52 and he played
Bombardier
or Navigator I don't remember but he was
good in that too
he had the military jargon down he was
real military man
Brian said I heard that Scott Baio was
originally supposed to be the main
character in Christine I always thought
he would have done good as Daniel loriso
I kind of thought so too like I'm Daniel
Larusso that's him in the karate kid
movie kid yeah yeah
um the thing about it like I love
the adaptation John Carpenter's
adaptation of Christine from 1983. I
think it's very very underrated
80s movie I think it's a very underrated
John Carpenter movie and I think it's a
very underrated Stephen King adaptation
I will say that I think
um Keith Gordon who played Arnie he was
great
I don't know if Scott Baio would have
pulled that off the same way Keith
Gordon was so good in it because
um
he was like
he equally sold this nebuchi
nerd
but then like when he kind of got
possessed by the car and like he turned
to this kind of like mean Greaser he
pulled that off too like in it was a
really seamless transition I just
thought he was really great in that it
was a great movie I love that movie I
actually I have a poster for that movie
right over there that's like framed on
the wall you guys like that movie read
the book The book's even better
uh it's close to the movie yeah they
actually yeah well that's always true
but yeah they did it's actually like a
pretty faithful adaptation they changed
a couple of things yeah but um like they
made it so that because in the book lebe
was the guy that sold him the car and
then he died and then he possessed
whereas like in this he was already dead
and then it was like the brother yeah so
you know no the Babe possessed it right
asked him after he died he died as soon
as he sold the car yeah like directly
right
but so they changed that in the movie
but not that like I said it didn't
really make it it was a great tale about
an evil [__] who was just
psychically tied to this damn car he
wanted a new body
so he could [__] [__] [__] up him in
that car and that car was like a demon
too
yeah I think the car was more of a demon
and he would in it and lebay's ghost was
in it they were like a they were like it
was like symbiotic yeah yeah it was it
was like yeah yeah and they sold it they
sold the [__] car to Arnie and
[__] the bay went in there and
croaked and Cat and His ghost went into
the [__] car
and then slowly his ghost took over and
then the car was happy about it it's a
good book
there's a lot more details of what's
going on inside that coach it's funny
because when because when you say when
you give somebody the elevator pitch and
say it's a it's a movie or a book about
a haunted car you're gonna be like come
on that sounds dumb as well more than
that it was more like [__] demonic
yeah it was actually like a demonic car
it was being haunted by an evil man and
they possessed a [__] kid or actually
he possessed a kid so him in the demon
car can continue their [__] love
affair right now I will note that
Stephen King wrote yet another book
about a haunted car which is called from
a Buick eight
which um was slightly different but kind
of similar enough that I was like
it was all right but I don't really
remember that much about it
um writers just like directors have
half-lives well they always have hits
well I yeah and the thing that I said
it's like look I'm still like a huge fan
of Stephen King's like older [__] yeah
and I can't
I can't keep track of all the stuff that
he writes because he writes so much like
you know what I mean so I can't keep up
with everything but I've mentioned this
before that I actually read a book of
his like the most recent book of his
that I read was um
um what the [__] was it called it's just
I just had it and it went like right out
of my head again
Revival and that's from like um 2014
2015 something like that and that's
great that was a great [__] book it
was just it reminded me kind of like of
Frankenstein or like Something Wicked
This Way Comes or something like that it
was like that kind of vibe and I was
like really really into it so it's not
that
it's not that he's like lost it or is
shit's not good or anything like that
but
you know just like anybody that writes
that much you're not everything's not
going to be like a [__] classic you
know what I mean and they tend to like
repeat themselves because it's Stephen
King so he's gonna have like particular
themes that he keeps returning to
because that's just what you do when
you're a writer you write what you're
interested in and that tends to be like
similar you know but um you know I I've
all of his new [__] that I've read
mostly
was good some of it was like like I said
Revival was great and I kind of wish
they would make a movie of that because
that would be [__] awesome but um
they'd probably [__] it up though oh
that needs a series that needs a series
because it's kind of sprawling like and
it happens over like a long period of
time so you mentioned they don't know
that what the problem was with the word
Oriental that's all [__] [__]
when I lived in Korea they didn't want
to be called Asians when he said Asia to
a Korean they think of [__] India
they called themselves Oriental in
English and they called us Occidental
it's just just an older terminology
doesn't mean anything Oracle said have
y'all seen hard candy yes I've seen it a
couple of times and it's awesome what is
I don't I don't think you've seen it
yeah matter of fact the number one
selling Korean beer is called OB
Oriental beer
oh B
it's [__] funny
but yeah um hard candy was about
um it's basically it was the guy that
plays uh Ed Warren in The Conjuring
movies
and um
Elliott page when she was when you know
when she was still Ellen Page she was a
kid but not a kid but she was like a
teenager
and she's like um
he plays like a pedo
there goes the monetization
uh a PDF file as they as they say he was
he's a PDF file yeah and um
and uh she's actually
sort of catfishing him into like she
knows about it and so she uses herself
as bait and then she sets up this big
elaborate but it's great it's a great
movie
um
I don't think have I reviewed it I
thought I did because I just watched it
not again like not too long ago
but
yeah High Desert 0404 said um I loved
Revival it was super lovecraftian yeah
that's what I was really surprised
because like I said I hadn't been
keeping up with Stephen King's newer
[__] because he like I said he just
writes so much and I have like so many
other writers that I follow and like
lots of other books that I have to read
and [__] like that so I didn't even I
had never even heard of that and then I
found it in a used bookstore
and I was like oh I never even heard of
this one like when's this from and I was
like that sounds kind of good and then I
read it I was like oh my God this is
amazing they need to like [__] make a
movie out of this like right now instead
of making
movies of stuff that they've already
made of his like remaking fire starter
and remaking pet cemetery and I was like
you already did that like he's got like
all these new ones
[__] he's got like a bunch of old books
and stories that they never made into
movies
that they should
I'm trying to think of what would be a
good
Stephen King story or book that they
never made into a movie is why
they've made so many movies of his [__]
that they've made movies of his [__]
that I'd even know they made movies of
the [__] you know what I'm saying I
found out a couple years back
that they had made a movie out of his
story Grandma which I think is from
was that a night shift or Skeleton Crew
I think it was in Skeleton Crew and they
made a movie out of it but it wasn't
called Grandma it was actually called
mercy and it had the kid in it that
played Carl on Walking Dead
um it wasn't bad I didn't I think I
wrote a review of it for my blog I
didn't love it because I think they
added too much extraneous because that's
a pretty short story right and it's
pretty straightforward so they added
like all this extraneous detail which I
thought they didn't really
developed sufficiently and I was like a
lot of this [__] just doesn't need to be
in here it's like it's just too busy and
it's like not really even that long of a
movie and it's like you could have
trimmed out some of these subplots and
some of these Side characters that
didn't have anything to do with anything
but it was overall it was an okay movie
though but
but I'm trying to think of like novels
of his that I've read that I thought
would make good movies that they never
did make into movies but
did they ever make bag of bones into a
movie
I kind of feel like they did but if they
did I didn't see it
I really liked bag of bones although I
haven't read it in a while
Ryan said I heard that Spielberg wanted
Stephen King to write the screenplay to
Poltergeist I would have loved that yeah
it probably would have been
as like I said we we were now we got
like all into Poltergeist it's like now
we're gonna go watch it again
I've probably seen Poltergeist like it's
I've probably seen that movie
at least 30 times
probably more than that I'd imagine
because it was always on like back in
the 80s it was always on
Patrick Wilson that's that guy's name
yeah
yeah it was like you know the guy the
guy that played Edward in all the
contract movies I can see his face and I
couldn't think of his name
um
Ryan says who thinks Dustin Hoffman
would have done awesome in horror films
he would have defined great acting and
horror now you know what I never thought
of that but now that I think about it
I mean yeah that might have worked the
thing about it I still kind of feel like
it's less now than it used to be but I
do kind of still feel like there's like
a stigma about horror movies
and people don't usually like call out
good acting in horror movies and there's
a lot of great acting in horror movies
and I've said this before and I will
defend this statement I kind of feel
like being in a horror movie is maybe
for an ad from an acting point of view
is probably harder than being in other
genres
because the emotions are so heightened
and a lot of times in horror movies you
have to sell an idea that is inherently
unbelievable so it's like a harder
uh hurdle to get over you know what I
mean like for your audience to make it
believable to make it realistic and so
like I think that that's more difficult
like from an acting point of view so I
think that we absolutely should
appreciate that I'm still mad that
[__]
Tony Collette didn't get nominated for
hereditary
because
that was just in any movie that was just
a [__] fantastic performance and I'm
just like pissed off and and there's and
I've seen like a lot of horror movies
that had [__] great performances in
them and they just don't get recognized
oh
Zach says they did do vagabones as a
mini series yeah I thought that they did
but it's like I thought they just did it
for like TV or something
it's like Pierce Brosnan was the main
character he wasn't very good hey yeah
I don't know some of the stuff I think
is actually works better as books you
know what's funny about that do you
remember the the Stephen King book
dreamcatcher the one with the ass
weasels
um that was the one with the ass weasels
that's how I know that book but well no
that's what they were so it was aliens
but kind of right it was an alien
infection of some kind but it was ass
weasels
but um I remember reading that book and
it's like the book's kind of fun
um it's pretty gross and it's like
entertaining but it's also like stupid
as hell and I remember reading that book
and being like oh this book is like
pretty fun but dear God I hope they
never make a [__] movie of this but
they did
and the movie not surprisingly was
[__] terrible
dream catcher oh dreamcatcher yeah I
remember when that book came out I never
read it
it's like I said it's from a body horror
standpoint it's like a fun if you just
want to read some of these kind of like
fun and gross because it's pretty gross
um you know it's not like great
literature or anything like that because
it's about ass weasels he asked me his
best ones were like
foreign
his last good ones were like thinner The
Dark Half
I guess the Talisman but he did that
with somebody else
Peter Peter Stroud yeah that was a good
that was a great book I wish they'd make
that into a damn series they might get
around to it well I told you I've told
you Gunslinger books were really good I
like that I I didn't read them all I
think I read three of them how many of
them are there now I think there's a
bunch there's a bunch of them 11 did
somebody tell me there's a lot I
wouldn't mind getting a series of them
all but man my vision is so bad I'm not
super into like because those are like
more fantasy based and I've never been
super excited I liked eyes of the Dragon
like that fantasy that you did back in
the 80s
but that's generally not my genre
I could read stories back back when I
was
late teens and early 20s and they could
capture my imagination but when I get
older reading fiction is not as quite as
exciting as it used to be like
it's not as immersive to me for some
reason I don't buy it as much
that's kind of sad maybe just because
you lost the you just got out of it and
yeah like I'd rather read a read a
biography an autobiography well I like
that too like I like history I like well
that's the thing but I I like both
things I'm I really like reading
nonfiction too like I really like
science and history and stuff like that
like oh and for a few years I went off
and that's all I read was like
non-fiction but
I don't know there's just something
about it depends on what kind of mood
I'm in but I can still get like totally
immersed in yeah in horror stories like
I said I'm not a big fantasy person
never have been I'm not a big sci-fi
person either although I do like some
sci-fi I'm more like a straight up
horror person and in within horror I
tend to have favorite subgenres but I'll
read pretty much any kind of horror like
within reason because I just I don't
know I just really the one that I'm
reading now I'm reading
um I just finished because I think was
it Oracle that recommended um the taking
Fisher book a house with good bones I
just finished that one
so I wrote a review of that so that'll
be going up not probably not this week
because I have another book review going
up this week but probably in a week or
two and right now I'm reading slew foot
by Brahm which is
set in it's kind of like the witch in
that it's set in like colonial America
and it's like a demonic like satanic
kind of thing and it's like it's really
good I just started it today and it's
like really I'm already like sucked into
it
um let's see John Gora said Straw Dogs
was kind of a horror film I'd agree
um it was pretty horrifying and um
have you seen High Desert uh says have
you seen a dark song yes I've seen it
two times and I actually I think I did a
review of it over on my flickers of fear
series I love that movie I think that
was one of the first movies that I ever
saw that like took the idea behind the
occult of doing like these long occult
rituals where you have to go like weeks
and weeks and weeks like without moving
or like without eating and like and like
really kind of like drilled down on that
yeah but it was really good it's only
two characters but I don't I really dug
it I really like that movie a lot
there's a set in Wales actually there's
something to all that though why rituals
would go on for that long
no you know
being you know having having Poltergeist
[__] experiences and [__] like that
not a body experiences ndes and stuff
sometimes it would take a long time like
when we were writing the book I started
getting into a mindset a couple weeks
later
phenomena started to happen it's not
something you can just turn on
it
it takes a mindset
and in my case
fear was a fear stress
and frustration where the main
feelings you have to have in order to
get it started so I could see how
maybe if somebody was trying to induce
that into themselves
by using some kind of magical system
that somebody else taught them to do
maybe the mental preparations would be
painful
like you can't move so it'd be able to
put you under a lot of stress
which kind of goes back to
rituals and Native Americans would kind
of do put themselves in a real hot tents
get heat exhausted you know hang
themselves from a ceiling from spikes
you know well because you're taking your
body to extreme to try and transcend to
try to [__] have it out of the body
right have auto body makes a lot of
sense
um
so not necessarily saying that the magic
itself worked it's just that putting
yourself under all that stress you had a
spiritual [__] experience and uh
possibly paranormal depending on who you
are and how it went down
most of it had to do for the Native
Americans was having visions
which yeah
that that that that that that matches up
with [__] that me and some of my friends
in the army would say have envisions
under extreme under under
the conditions of extreme exhaustion
and then the vision comes true that kind
of [__] but it's usually little [__]
that would only matter to the people
involved
so I guess they were doing that even
back then
but the movie a dark song the brain is
the brain is a prediction machine anyway
it predicts every little thing you're
doing just walking around
so it may not be may not be Supernatural
it might just be a type of quantum
computation
where you correctly guessed what the
future would be because
your subconscious had mapped out the
course of events
many steps ahead of what your
Consciousness could do
I tried to figure it out you know what I
mean
why a premonition would come true why
you would dream true
somebody say well maybe it's just luck
statistics
I don't know man
some weird dreams that I had that came
true had a weird feeling to them but
from the very beginning
um a dark song was about a woman who her
son had died and she hired an occultist
because he said that he could that they
could do this really long ritual and she
would be able to talk to him again but
they had to close themselves up in this
house for like six months and like she
had to do
all of these like rituals and [__] like
that but it's also it's kind of
Supernatural but it's also like kind of
psychological horror because you're not
really sure what her end game is you're
not really sure what his end game is
like if he can really do what he says he
can do like what he said he could do and
all this other kind of [__] so there's
like all this tension between them but
it's really really good I really liked
it a lot
um Zach said how many people do you
think uh knew Shawshank was a king story
yeah I don't know if a lot of people did
know that because it's not horror horror
but Stephen King writes a lot of stuff
that's not straight up horror yeah and
that's got his fingerprints all over it
it does though
but I think maybe a lot of people I mean
you know something or something like The
Green Mile or something like that do you
read his short stories a lot of them are
like that yeah he does write a lot of
short stories like along that along that
vein and then necessarily paranormal
well yeah they're weird you know like
the jaunt
that was a [__] weird one you know
and then the guy who ate himself out on
that island what was that called
Survivor time Survivor type yeah and
then the Mist another good one they did
Survivor type on um the new Creep Show
on shutter they did it as like an
animated yeah yeah it was good which was
probably the best thing to do because
it's like that would be really hard to
do like with a per because like it's a
person like eating themselves piece by
piece that'd be kind of hard enough to
avoid starvation yeah
John Gore said weren't they going to
make the king's short uh rage I think it
was called about the school shooter
hostage situation yeah that's when he
was writing under um Richard Bachmann
and that was like a novella
and I kind of feel like they were gonna
make it but then I don't know if they
might make it nowadays but it's like
it's kind of too close to like a lot of
real school shootings so people might be
a little sensitive about it but you know
um
oh Zach says there's a 2019 horror movie
based on Jewish practices I learned
about called the vigil that looks
awesome I've seen that
um I actually did a review of it
probably like a few months ago like it's
over I think it's in my flickers of your
playlist
it was actually pretty good um the
director that did it I think it was the
same director that did the fire starter
remake recently
um and that's one of the reasons that I
went back and like watched it it's
pretty good it's like it's not
it's not like Reinventing the wheel it's
pretty much just like I mean the whole
premise is like the guy is supposed to
um
you know watch over the dead body until
the because that's you know Jewish
tradition like you're supposed to watch
over the dead body until the you know
morgue attendance like come to get it
the next day or whatever and there's
another woman in the house and she has
dementia but then like it starts like
all this weird like creepy paranormal
[__] starts to happen it's actually it's
pretty good but it's not like super
original or anything like that but I
really liked it
um let's see
uh and Oracle says talking about uh
Stand By Me the movie yeah that was also
based on Stephen King the body and again
not Supernatural YP Pro mentions
psychotic breaks due to sleep
deprivation I used to set the
pre-consciousness yeah
yeah
yeah I just noticed that uh
anything that alters Consciousness to
some kind of a [__] extreme degree
you can have a weird experience
uh might be through
like you said sleep deprivation
extreme fatigue
uh psychedelic drugs
extreme
um emotional states especially if it's
over a period of time
one of the ones that [__]
consistently did it for me was basically
kind of like Transcendental Meditation
where you try to stop all thought
which is mad
try to stop it stopping your conscious
thinking is extremely difficult yeah as
soon as you do you'll have an out of
Body Experience
my brain is like a [__] hamster it's
just going all the time
silence and then all of a sudden you're
[__] feels like you fell asleep
without the Consciousness and you'll be
looking down at yourself
it'll feel like your head's rocking back
and forth too
but yeah honestly I think Stand by Me
was uh one of the best movies made from
the Stephen King and like I said I don't
even know I guess most people know that
that's from a Stephen King story
but again that's not
necessarily horror
it's horror adjacent I guess
but he he wrote like a lot of kind of
drama type stuff that wasn't
Supernatural and a lot of it was really
good I thought like look at something
like Dolores Claiborne or something like
that that's not Supernatural
but that was like a really good
just a reminder a few people listening
to this recorded uh super thanks of
course are active and uh super chats are
active if you guys are listening live
just passing the collection played
around
yeah Kalyn Higgins Stand By Me as
Stephen King right yeah it was based on
a um story called The Body uh also
didn't Stephen King write a book that
was banned in public schools because a
mass Shooter had a copy yeah I think
that's what everybody's talking about
it's a novella and it's called rage and
it was in
um it was called the Bachmann books and
it had four novellas in it it was rage
the long walk
uh uh the running man yeah and one other
one a lot of people don't know that the
Arnold Schwarzenegger movement running
man is a [__] that's also a Stephen
King but he wrote it under Richard
Bachman yeah
and uh even though I love that movie
they cut so much of the good [__] out of
that movie there's no blood in it there
hardly isn't any killing in any of the
seeds it's very tame apt pupil that was
the other one thing to see it by today's
they made that into a movie too
but uh I recommend running man it's a
fun it's a fun program
I've heard that they're making the long
walk into a movie but yeah running man
was not like
the movie wasn't like the book no not
really no I mean the premise is sort of
similar yeah but it didn't have the same
visuals and the thing about it was the
story was actually much darker like more
dystopian it's like they they kind of
made the movie like more fun you know
what I mean
more fun more colorful
um Zach says have you ever seen ask a
mortician here on YouTube yes I love her
she's awesome
I don't like you know I'm subscribed I
don't see all her videos but I do watch
them like every now and then yeah she's
like super cool yeah King in his head
hey Dave was really good he was great
um I haven't read anything recently I
mean some of his stuff might be good but
Tommyknockers came out and I was
disappointed and I stopped reading after
that well since I had to go to the Army
well like I said it's like I didn't like
the timing knockers either but like I
said that's alien stuff and I'm not
usually into aliens
he was he was tripping balls that book
did not make any goddamn sense it jumped
everywhere well he was a big alcoholic
and he was hopped up on coke a lot of
times yeah
and honestly like in a way like and I
know he says that he's like oh yeah I
don't even remember writing that [__] or
whatever but uh he he's pretty like open
about all of his substance abuse issues
but in a way like yeah that's [__] up
and like some of the books that came out
in that era like weren't that great but
then in another way I'm kind of like I'm
kind of amazed that he could like write
a novel and it could be like pretty much
coherent when he was that [__] up I'm
like [__] I know people that are like
Stone Cold Sober that couldn't do that
so yeah but it didn't compare to say
like the stand well no or The Shining or
you know some of those the books are the
[__] masterpieces uh
I was really into stand we haven't
talked much about that but I [__]
love that book I need to reread that one
of these days I keep me I keep meaning
to it's good well I need to get I think
the only version I have of it is the old
paperback version and they've since
released like the unabridged big ass
doorstop version and that's the one I
need to get and I really enjoy it
thinner
and I really enjoyed [__]
um The Dark Half I thought that was
really good I really liked that book
actually the movie's pretty good too
it's kind of Dylan was from Mississippi
it's kind of cheesy but I was kind of
into it yeah we might have reviewed that
not too long ago now that I'm thinking
about it
Dark Tower and the Gunslinger stuff that
I read was really good and then uh
Talisman was [__] great
um like I said he only co-authored that
I told you they did a sequel to that
right Stephen King and Peter shroud but
years ago it's called the black house
okay I actually just thought of the
bookstore the other day it was years ago
that came out but I don't I remember the
Talisman I don't think I ever read the
black house and I read it and it was
pretty good
um although I think I liked uh Christine
better
some of his early stuff was the book
Christian is actually like really good
yeah and Carrie was pretty good too and
that's his first novel yeah it's pretty
good he had written short stories prior
to that but that was his first published
novel
all writers it's like if their first
novel that was published that's not the
first novel that I wrote I guarantee it
I'd take Christine over Kerry
scene is better written yeah
like I said Terry was very early in his
career I mean Christine was pretty early
too that's the story you know yeah
I mean a lot of that or that early [__]
like of his
um Zach was saying that the first pet
cemetery is so good I mean the book is
awesome I love the book of pet cemetery
that was for a while like that was my
favorite scene I don't think I read that
one oh it's awesome I don't think I read
it the reason that I liked it so much
was because it was [__]
vicious I mean just the the fact that he
just like imagined like the whole scene
where he described that little kid
getting like run over by the truck and
like just the [__] and I was just
like damn this is [__]
it was it was a lot I also like Salem's
Lot I did as well even though that was
like his take on Dracula and he says
that he's like I basically just took
Dracula and wrote my own version of it I
thought it was great but yeah it came
out really good
it came out really good it made for TV
movies great too got it on the Toby
Hooper one yeah we got it on Blu-ray too
yeah I've seen I've seen that a bunch of
times and and that's one of the best one
of the best Stephen King Adams was good
because I forgot at the very end they
became vampire Hunters were traveling
the [__] world
they're gonna have a whole series now
like Kung Fu yeah I forgot that they
left it open like that
ah John Gore said writers and alcohol
seem to go hand in hand well the thing
about that
look I'm a writer um I'm not a drunk or
anything I do like a drink obviously but
I'm I think it's because anybody that's
real into
those kind of creative Endeavors
particularly writing because writing is
so
solitary
and a lot of people if you're just kind
of sitting around for hours and hours
every day just like inside your own head
and coming up with [__] all the time
yeah it kind of wears on you after a
while it doesn't I no it doesn't bother
me because I'm kind of a solitary person
anyway so it doesn't it doesn't get to
me I think the way that it would maybe
get to other people
but I see that I I can see how
how that would happen Victor Garcia he
said the [__] the stand is my
all-time favorite read it twice in high
school I'll tell you what Victor I think
the stand made me and you gay I think
that's how that [__] happened is is this
year coming out I'm coming out coming
out now really yeah
I long suspected it you're finally
admitting
the evicted became gay watching the
listening to reading the stand you know
um somebody I forgot who it was was it
was it um
was it Louis Hernandez he sent me the
stand remastered [__] blue it might
have been yeah I think it might have
been a little Louisiana
it was made for TV
I hadn't seen in a long time and they
had a VHS copy
of free to watch it and I couldn't get
through 20 minutes about how much it
looked like [__] and I think it might
have been Louie
sent me for free
a Blu-ray copy that they that's out and
and I haven't seen that on any of the
streaming service Services of the stand
it was made for TV all-star cast too
yeah everybody was in that everybody
was in it Molly Ringwald was in it yeah
dude who played Martin the Martian was
in it yeah
had a uh [__] and it's it's pretty
close pretty close uh from what I can
remember to the to to the book
I like this stand but like I said I'm
not Tom loves like post-apocalyptic
stuff yeah and sci-fi stuff I like some
of that stuff but it like I said it's
not my preferred I'm more into like
straight up horror I love psychological
horror surrealist horror haunted house
[__]
um old school witchcraft [__] I like
that kind of stuff see look man he's
good
Garcia he's saying that there's a gay
scene in both in stand and it so that
that's what that's that's right that's
how we got flipped
well that is I'm a suit
[Laughter]
I'm gonna sue for damages yeah super
damages because it made you gay
I'm just I'm glad that you're finally
admitting it Thomas like glad that
you're finally living your truth
it's my coming out party I know this is
awesome I'm very excited about it
so who are you gonna are you gonna like
get some dudes over here so I can like
film something
now Jenny's trying to get a [__]
Devil's threesome
come on let's get this started Jenny's
looking for some animals trying to get
get into a man sandwich right or I could
just lay back there in the bed and watch
and like film it yeah watch it at my
leisure
it says
writing fiction like acting at least
skirts possession sometimes
it does kind of I have no noticed that
when I've
written stuff that I thought was some of
my best stuff you kind of go into
a Fugue state
which is like for a while I actually
preferred to write by hand so I would
buy big notebooks and because then you
could do almost do like automatic
writing because sometimes like you know
you start writing it I'd be like God
what the [__] I don't know where I'm
going with this story because I like
have an idea but then I'd be like I
don't know what I'm gonna do with this
but then if you just like stop thinking
and then just kind of let like your hand
move and then like sometimes like you'll
read it back and be like you know what
that's that's pretty good yeah
right right so that's kind of what I
started doing same thing when I was
getting into drawing yeah you have to
like let it you have to allow it well I
[__] I read a book on it first okay
yeah drawing on the right right yeah
yeah yeah that's a very famous book
right and uh what ends up happening is
that once you learn the [__]
technique of just like clicking oh
clicking over and shutting off your
[__]
the left side of your brain so you're
not doing any analytical thinking like I
have well I have to stop you just allow
the right side to do it which is the it
it's it's got a lot better spatial
awareness
and then I'll be drawn and I was doing
female nudes until I was wrong
the faces the bodies everything
and um no plan I could just do it and
what was funny is I can remember
starting
and then 45 15 minutes later I was done
or starting to come to the end of it and
I can't remember what I did but then
there's this beautiful draw in there
yeah yeah that's how I wrote some of my
story how did I do that so it's weird
because Gestalt and movement in it and
[__] depth and yeah and I wasn't
using any of the [__] mechanical
cheating things where you're looking
through the eye you know trying to no it
was just all by hand
and that's I guess you can do that with
literature too huh yeah of course yeah
okay well that's what I mean I think my
best stories came about when I well
because I mean you know me you know what
I'm like I I'm a classic overthinker I
have horrible anxiety I'm a
perfectionist so I had a long thing and
this is crazy and this is kind of going
back to the Stephen King thing like we
were talking about before because for a
long time like I've been writing horror
stories since I can remember since I
knew how to write because that was all I
wanted to do
and
because I was such a perfectionist
growing up
um I had this weird idea that it's like
well if I write a story it has to be
perfect right out the gate
or it's not good enough like I'm just
gonna throw it away so I did that for
like many many years and I kept not
finishing things or just be like oh that
was not good enough and I would just
Chuck it out or whatever and then I read
because it took me like so many years to
figure this out I'm just like kind of
embarrassed about it but um I read
Stephen King's non-fiction book which is
called on writing which is kind of about
his writing advice and like kind of a
memoir and stuff like that and that book
he was basically just like well just
don't think about it just like [__]
don't do an outline don't do any because
I always try to do like outlines because
I was like I need to know where I'm
going with this story and everything
like that he's like [__] don't do
that he's like I don't do that now some
writers do some some writers actually
work better that way
um but I discovered that I am not one of
those writers he's like I don't plan
anything I just come up with a [__]
situation and some characters I was like
I want to put these situations in this
character and then bam I'm just gonna go
and see where it goes I'm not gonna
think about it I'm not gonna try and
direct it I'm just gonna let it
organically just like go where it's
going and he's like and sometimes I'm
surprised you know because I didn't
expect you to go that way and so I was
like you know what I'm gonna try that
out because I'd never done that before I
always try to like outline everything
like down to the last chapter and stuff
and I tried doing it like that and it
was much better because then that way I
just could turn my brain off
and I would just be like okay I have an
idea about XYZ this is a story I want to
write about and it's like just stop
thinking and just like write and my
stories came out much much better and
like I said and they wouldn't and then I
sometimes I would be surprised like how
they ended up like oh I didn't expect it
to go in that direction all right we're
going in that direction now and you just
let it go in that direction like don't
try to force it into like I said some
people do seem to do better like with
outlines and stuff but I'm not one of
those people John Cora said that the
dude from RoboCop to play the Yuppie guy
was in The Stand movie yeah that's right
um he those were two good roles that
that actor played I don't know that
actor's name
but in his day man he was he got some
interesting roles
in Robocop he played the the ocp guy who
got [__] RoboCop's contract his
contract [__] going
the RoboCop prop project going you ended
up getting killed by Clarence botiker
put a grenade shot him up shot his legs
Out Underneath Him kicked his coat cores
out of his house and threw a [__]
Grenade on him and blew his ass up
and that was the first time they ever
showed DVD was in that scene dude took
out the little [__] disc you put it
in and it played on the TV ooh
futuristic yeah wow futuristic [__]
and in the stand he played Randall Flagg
the devil played Randall Flags right
hand man I think his name was Poke if I
remember correctly poke something or
other was that was his criminal name he
was doing a license life in prison why
do you think they called him Pope he was
pokerizing people
that was that was not where my brain
went I'll admit
no
you got life in prison for killing a guy
and uh
in a [__] robbery
and while I was in prison
he uh saved some rats and some foods and
everybody else starved out and he was he
he was the last Survivor on his cell
block
Ed in that [__] cell with those dead
bodies
he was eating them eating a rat
and the [__] devil appeared to him
and said if you pledge yourself to me
I'll let you out of there and he let him
out and he became the devil's right-hand
man as a [__] great it was a great
scene that's good character too creepy
he was scared of the devil but he served
him and he ended up becoming a went from
a piece of [__] to a criminal mastermind
[__] he helped run the city and [__]
for the devil
the good book real good
yeah Camp guy said Betty Edward's
drawing on the right side of the brain
one of the most famous art books in
history yeah it was her theory was that
anybody could learn to draw just like we
all learned to read uh we focus more on
reading than drawing see some of the
before and after self portraits by
untrained Artisan or drawing class
they're posting on the internet yeah and
I think that true of any like I said any
artistic endeavor
and I have to kind of like constantly
tell myself this all the time is that
you really have to like not it works
better most of the time in you don't
think about her too hard like if you
just kind of like let it
naturally and I mean for sure I found
myself writing a lot more and my [__]
was coming out a lot better and I was
actually finishing stuff when I stopped
thinking about it
and just kind of like you kind of led
into a trance let it happen it is a
little like it's not like a ooh like a
mystical it's nothing like that
um you know I wouldn't go that far but
it is kind of like a you get into a Zone
you're not checking yourself you're just
allowing it yeah you're just allowing it
because the thing about it and like I
said this is something that actually
reading Stephen King's on writing like
actually got me to stop doing was that I
felt like it had to be like I said
perfect first time out and he's just
like [__] that just write it it's like
you can fix it later you know what I
mean it's like if you [__] something up
if you like contradict yourself or
something it's like it's not a big deal
just like write it all out it's like
just go back and read it and you can fix
it later on it's fine it's fiction
you're just making it up so it's like
you and I was like oh yeah duh because I
was like sitting there thinking well if
it's not right like the first time out
it's like it's not I have to throw it
away I don't know why I thought that but
I thought that for like many years and
that's why I never finished anything
but
and honestly like what I started doing
I've been working on a novel for a
really long time just I haven't had time
to work on it like the last couple years
but I've had the idea for a long time
and I'm still gonna finish it God damn
it I'm like 20 000 words in so I'm not
throwing that out and it's good like
what I've written so far I was reading
it back over and I'm just like okay I
definitely have to finish this because
it's awesome but um
I started getting into because we've
been talking about like um Ai and stuff
and I started getting into some of the
apps that like help you with the AI
writing and stuff and I was kind of
curious to see because there are some AI
generators that will generate a whole I
mean technically you can generate like a
whole novel or a whole screenplay or
something like that and I just wanted to
see what would happen What
read this read the comments go ahead go
ahead I'm just I just read a comments
[__] started laughing fast
what about Transcendental Meditation
going gay in the bathroom they're in
there fighting each other in a bath
house your mind is not the only thing
getting blown yeah that sounds like a
like something that should be on a movie
post yeah
but um but yes yeah so okay good good so
I wanted to see um
what it would do so I gave it a prompt
like for a horror novel idea that I had
and it wasn't like super complicated or
anything like that it was just like a
like a couple sentences I was like write
me a novel about this
and so it did like it came up with all
the characters it came up with an
outline which was pretty decent like I
read through it I'm like yeah that's
that could work and then like I let it
write like each chapter out
and then when I was reading it back I
was like the the individual paragraphs
and stuff like that are
fine are like well written but one thing
I noticed that it does and I've heard
this from other writers that use AI to
help out their [__] like you know to get
past writer's block and stuff and
they're just like one thing that I've
noticed is particularly across if you're
working on like a longer work is it will
repeat itself
so I'm reading the first chapter
and the first scene it was I was like oh
this is pretty good you know what I mean
it's like it's not great it's a little
overwrought like I would kind of tone it
down a little bit because it's very much
like a like a pulpy uh you know airport
type of Novel
um that kind of thing and I was just
like that's not my style
so I was like so I'd have to tone that
down a little bit but I was like but
it's okay it's like it's well written
it's grammatically correct it's you know
it's there's some good [__] going on in
there but then I noticed like so the
first scene was good I'm like okay this
is pretty good but then I noticed that
the next scene I was like well this
scene is pretty much just like the first
scene except slightly different like
worded slightly different so I noticed
that like the first three or four scenes
of the first chapter were essentially
like the same scene over and over again
just like with different dialogue but it
was kind of like the same information
that it was imparting and I'm just like
okay okay the show hit two hours you
want to go ahead and shut it down well
oh well no but okay well you did you
want to watch a movie
yeah I guess we're good okay
um okay I was laughing what they were
talking about it's like what was it
somebody's ass would just Transcendental
Meditation make you gay and then they're
talking about Transcendental Meditation
in a bath house although your spirit is
getting blown in your mind is getting
blown Transcendental Meditation to make
you gay because you'll transcend the
body and it'll just be Souls so it can't
be gay in the [__] spirit world it's
just spirits
yeah yeah
Kaylin Higgins says automatic writing
works best for people who have an innate
sense of cohesion and practicality which
I which I do actually uh most messy
writers and I've met a few neat outlines
and Direction yeah some people do like I
said it's just I was trying to force
myself into the outline thing because I
felt like that I was always taught
that's what you were supposed to do
um but after Stephen King said man [__]
that I don't ever do that I was like
maybe I should try not doing that and I
found that it worked much better for me
but like I said I know it does work
better for other people like they need a
goal to work toward like it's like I
know need to know the story is going
this like toward this end or whatever
but it's like I don't I don't work very
well like that hey there's Pookie
um
Poe says so AI is better for a novella
or let well I don't even know about that
it's you still need a person to direct
the story because when you do AI
um if you just have it generate the
story even if you give it like a decent
prompt and stuff like that it doesn't
know
um like it'll mix characters up it'll
like come up with [__] that doesn't have
anything to do with your original [__]
like it'll you know what I mean it does
like weird stuff still so you still need
like a lot of human Direction one thing
that aif I found that is good for is if
you already have like this super
detailed idea and you already have like
a bunch of stuff written it will help
you because if you have enough in there
it learns your style to a degree
um so you can be like oh but you got to
this one paragraph and you're just like
stuck I don't know what's gonna happen
next and then you can like click and
it'll give you like ideas and like in
your style more or less and you can kind
of like take pieces like oh yeah that's
kind of a good idea or something like
that but it but just generating stuff
from nothing or just from like an idea
it doesn't seem to be able to do that
all that well yet like especially like
in a longer like a more complex most of
the people kind of work know that are
working on it
you're not gonna really see
much amazing things out of out of that
kind of AI until about four or five
years from now yeah I mean from what
I've seen it's impressive for
um getting through writer's block it's
impressive if you already have a lot of
stuff written and you can put it in
there so it learns what your style is
like so it can kind of help you out and
like give you suggestions like maybe you
want to go this direction and that kind
of sounds like something you would have
written
so it's good for that but just
generating stuff from scratch
not so much like the writing is good
it's all grammatically correct it's you
know written well it's you know each
individual paragraph could have come
from like a best-selling novel but when
you put them all together like in
aggregate
it doesn't it makes sense but
it contradicts itself it goes off in
weird directions that you didn't expect
like it mixes characters up it does [__]
like that it's gonna have to be human
guided that's well yeah and that's kind
of like the way that a lot of writers
are using it because that's kind of what
you have you can't just come up with
like a whole novel that's publishing you
say that that [__] writes great legal
writs too well yeah but that's not right
I can I can see that it takes human
rights everything does everything does
yeah
but you know but I don't think it'll
always be like that 10 years from now
it'll probably be pretty damn good
if you have legal trouble you'll be able
to download a [__] app and you have a
[__] lawyer and you're [__] Palm
in your hand writing writs for you and
making motions in court
now I can see that
yeah
and I mean the the thing about it like I
said it's another thing that I noticed
and I just kind of I kind of alluded to
this before but it's just very
repetitive one thing I noticed too that
it did
in the novel that I had it generate like
it was a cool idea like I came up with
the idea and then it came up with like
its own ideas and I was like oh that's
kind of neat
um you know what I mean but then like
when it was writing the scenes like it
would
um repeat scenes but like different you
know like the dialogue was different but
it was essentially like the same thing
like it was saying the same thing like
it was very repetitive or it would have
different characters like saying the
exact same thing like at different times
in this story so it wasn't real good at
like differentiating characters from one
another they all kind of sounded alike
that was another thing that I noticed
because the one that I generated was
like a family so it was like a mom and a
dad and like a couple kids and all of
them sounded when they talked it all
sounded like the same person talking you
know what I mean yeah so it was that so
you definitely do need
because I was curious it was kind of
like an experiment I wanted to see what
would happen but um it's much better if
you have a lot of your own [__] in there
and you just kind of like use it to help
you out like
if you can't think of like something to
put next you know what I mean it's like
or I don't really have an idea of where
I want to go from here give me some
ideas like give me a couple paragraph
ideas like Oh I like that or I like that
part and I can use that and you don't
have to use like the what they wrote you
can kind of change it around it just
like kind of gives you ideas you know
what I mean
um let's see
can't I said I always had trouble
getting my son to generate something
original out of his own head when I was
helping him with his English composition
class
he just didn't have the the love of
reading and writing that I had he's good
at math and other stuff just lazy when
it comes to thinking and putting some
things out and writing too many video
games and not enough reading yeah I
think that kind of is a problem I don't
know if video games per se are the
problem but I mean I really love to read
and I grew up reading and I think that's
a lot better
I don't know it just exercises your
imagination a lot better people aren't
developing the same way because you have
to picture everything you have to build
worlds in your head and I think that's
like a lot better
yeah uh the younger Generations are not
like us you know if you Gen X or older
Millennials are
simple closer to gemin and Gen X and
some of these real young people because
we just didn't grow up with all these
damn distractions we had internet and
everything but it
didn't have ai I mean I didn't have
internet until I was already out I was
already grown yeah and like we
um
we had video games but video games
weren't immersive as they are now
and we didn't have social media
you know or dating apps and [__] you had
to go meet women in the wild
you had to have game and you had to Dart
them on the Serengeti [__] right you
had to drag them back to your yeah hey
[__] mouth game you had to try to
talk in and how to dress and you know
they're not really growing up that way
they don't even go to clubs
from what I understand it's evidently a
lot of them don't even go to clubs they
probably can't afford to
in Florida though we're still a club
scene and there are young people in the
clubs and young guys in the clubs and
they're aggressive they're going for
women grabbing Jenny's ass I gotta fight
them and it's just you know and they're
in their 20s so yeah I mean a lot of
people like it but according to what I'm
seeing online up north in California
it's dead you know they're not like
South is the last Bastion of [__]
tits and ass and alcohol you know it's
just this place hasn't changed much it's
a resort area
and the guys that grew up here are
aggressive and uh the girls the same way
and
I hang out at Starbucks here locally and
watch people of all different
Generations go in there and get [__]
Starbucks [__]
and we still got physically fit young
dudes and physically fit athletic
females and stuff
obesity isn't a huge problem here you
got fat people but this is the older
people and a lot of them don't seem to
be from here
um you know like when we went to the
movie theater I was like God damn we're
the only people here aren't fat
but I got the feeling that they weren't
they like you said they were retirees
when you say when you say yeah I mean
there's not don't get me wrong there's I
grew I was born in Florida yeah you got
fat people and there's a lot of fat
people there that were born here so
right but he's still got a lot of fit
good looking people here you know
um
so I don't really know what's going on
in the rest of the United States I
haven't really been out of here in about
10 years now I heard the fittest people
in the United States are actually in
Colorado probably somewhere yeah
I don't know if that's still the case
but that's what I had
but it's kind of it's still you know
having left the South to come back to it
coming back to it this still feels like
the South to me
especially in the more rural areas
where where we are now it feels like
South
well we live in a pretty rural yeah
I mean it's not in the middle of nowhere
but it's pretty yeah farmy well compared
to Mississippi this is the suburbs like
right across the street from our
neighborhood is like a huge Farm yeah
although those are all going
they're all being sold well I imagine
that they will build it out well just
because where where we met in where we
lived in Sanford yeah when we first
moved there that was rural it was pretty
rural but then like by the time we left
it was so like built up yeah
10 years
Victor said I was one of two kids in my
small Rural High School who had internet
at home in 1996. yeah that was right
about I think we got internet in it was
95 or 96. yeah I loved I love 90s
internet man I loved it
you felt like you were really getting
away with some [__] but like I said I
was I was out of high school yeah I
graduated in 1990 so we didn't have
internet in high school I guess it was
around 97.
I [__]
was hanging out with my first wife this
before I married her
I went online and went on to an online
Hot Topic store they had an amazing
selection and bought us a bunch of
clothes
and I mean those days clothes were still
expensive it wasn't like she and where
you can get a five dollar shirt I Must
Have Spent 300 a [__] on on clothes
and got all this [__] golf clothes
delivered to the [__] house using a
[__] ATM card and I thought I was in
[__] running man or something some
futuristic
movie with Arnold Schwarzenegger I
couldn't believe that I didn't have to
go to a mall to get that because that's
the way it used to be
and then when that [__] got delivered
and I saw his clothes I looked at that
foot I thought of that shopping mall and
I was like what the [__] is it what the
[__] is that what is what purpose does
that serve now
and I called it because [__] decades
later all those [__] balls went out
of [__] business
all my shopping
although it's crazy because I mean the
mall we go to it's not a dead mall I
wouldn't call it that
the Lake Square Mall which is the
closest one to our house which is still
18 miles away yeah
um it's not a dead mall but it's because
most of the stores are occupied
but it's not traditional mall stores
though bustling yeah it's [__] like
barber shops Pet Shops
well there's a Pet Smart in there
there's a books a million in there
there's a movie theater there's a police
station in there there's that that's in
pretty much every mall now yeah there's
a bath and body where I think there's a
recruiter's [__] station there's one
of those in every Mall nowadays too well
actually that's not even nowadays
because I remember the mall in Daytona
had one had a uh Marines recruitment
since I was a kid so that's pretty cool
you need to have [__] uh
like what Hickory Farms yeah yeah See's
Candy remember that yeah we didn't have
one of those we did have Hickory Farms
it wasn't a storefront though they would
always do like a like a um like a booth
thing in the middle but they would only
do that around holiday and have at least
at least two different competing record
stores those don't exist yeah our Mall
had Camelot right and then later it had
record Town yeah record town I worked
there yeah in the 90s the late 80s or
early 90s then they had a bunch of
[__] cheesy [__] clothing
shops and some trinket shops and none of
that none of that's really in there
anymore
those don't sell in malls anymore
I noticed that a lot of like our Mall
when I when I was growing up in Daytona
it had like a [__] million shoes and
most of the department stores are gone
out of that mall they're closed down
there's no serious fye's Spencer Gifts
yeah there are no they're still in FYE
in the Altamonte Mall yeah which
actually still looks like it does
because it's always crowded when we go
we're not crowded but there's always
like a lot of customers in there well
they have cool [__]
they have
um I bought like a ton of t-shirts in
there I buy DVDs in there like when they
have box sets of [__] in that uh ball
the most popular things are
the bookstore the AMC theater the food
court
the pet store yeah
so I think that's what yeah the
barbershop I mean Barbershop was in
there it was fun that Barbershop is
always like it's an old school barber
shop yeah
that's always full yeah every time we go
in there and the PetSmart is usually
like pretty bustling that's where we
adopted um our new kitty from yeah but
she came from the hofmeyer shelter yeah
but they had just brought her over that
morning and she was at PetSmart that's
where we got her from but that book's a
million is always like pretty busy yeah
I noticed though that the inventory
isn't turn it over
well a lot of people don't buy books I
do well all the tickets though and all
the little [__] toys and the
Collectibles and the dolls and [__] that
they had I don't call it I kind of want
here's the thing like they haven't
turned it over they have
um
Trivial Pursuit the horror Edition
and I want that so bad well they have
like the big board game version which is
like 50 bucks but then they have like
the little just the just the cards
without the board and everything and I
think that's just like 20 bucks and it's
like I kind of want that but
um I'm just like if I bought this Tom
wouldn't play with me because I would
just win
because he wouldn't know any other [__]
so it's not even it wouldn't even get
into that right so it's like so so it's
like that wouldn't be any fun for him
but it was just kind of like I don't
know maybe I should buy it anyway and
then we could just play it on the show
that would be fun but because I kind of
want it
I have like some apps on my phone that
are horror um
like horror trivia games on my phone but
I'm really good at them as long as it
doesn't go too much into
the Gap in my horror knowledge I'm gonna
say
is probably like
mid 90s to late 2000s
like I saw a lot of horror movies in
that time period but a lot of those
horror movies I just kind of like
checked out of the [__] and I was like
no it's a nevermind I'm just gonna watch
the old [__] like but because a lot of
the [__] seemed like it was just like
remakes of old stuff or everything was
just kind of like
Scream rip-offs After 1996
um and I just kind of lost interest I
didn't and or it was just like a big CGI
Fest
so
so there's kind of like a big gap in
mind so like that whole like I Know What
You Did Last Summer and all that kind of
so like that came out of the 90s I
didn't see a lot of those or if I did I
don't even remember them like enough to
answer questions about them
and I kind of feel like the same thing
happened in the early 2000s like
everything was just kind of like remix
and I didn't bother with a lot of them
so there's so there's kind of a I did
notice when I was doing some of the um
horror games on my phone that anytime
the question was about something that
came out like
from 2000 to
2009 or something like that I was just
like
I've heard of that movie but I've never
seen it so I don't know you know what I
mean because like I just didn't bother
with it
um let's see
yeah B Dalton's yeah um the mall where I
grew up in Daytona we also had
two bookstores we had Waldo books and B
Daltons and um
yeah I used to spend a lot of time in
there I do like
I do like the the bigger bookstores in
the web but you know it just seems like
this mall we have a walk through the
whole thing like I haven't really
noticed
we just basically go in the bookstore or
the pet store which are like right
across from each other and then like the
movie theater
but
it looks like most of the storefronts
are occupied but
it doesn't really have any huge anchor
well PetSmart's an anchor
Books-A-Million is an anchor the reason
why we're talking about this because we
we like the dead Mall videos and like
Dan Bell and I was learning modelology
which is like the spaces and Aces
Adventures what keeps them all
just
and it's just kind of funny you know
being our age we're kind of nostalgic
for the old style of merchandising how
they used to sell things
because there was a whole culture built
around that it's funny to see all that
vanish
well it's interesting from uh how
progress from an archaeological right
it's like an archeology standpoint right
I don't have any project I'm not a super
nostalgic person
like um you know I like a lot of [__]
from the 80 like music and movies and
stuff like that but I'm not kind of one
of those people it's like oh [__] sucks
nowadays I wish we could go back to the
old days like I would never I'm not like
that
um but no it's easier now buying things
is a lot that's what I mean it's like I
wouldn't go back there was a there was
some [__] that was a lot cooler back
then like I said and I will argue that a
lot of the music was good and like a lot
of the movies were good and stuff but
I'm not gonna say that it's like oh
there's not good [__] nowadays because
there is like I've seen some amazing
[__] movies nowadays it was a mix
back then too but y'all kids are taking
for [__] granted is the corticoprias
of course how do I say it of course
your choices are [__] unlimited with
online shopping
I mean yeah you're really lucky yeah we
couldn't do that we couldn't do that
back then we wish we could have done
that yeah because there's so many
clothes because I wish there was like so
much [__] that I wanted and I couldn't
find it or I couldn't afford it or
nobody made it you wouldn't know what a
band sounded like yeah you had to buy
the album first or you had to hurt from
your friend
and then you would go to the record
store and try to discover new music
you're taking a risk it was like 20
bucks for a house that was a lot of it
it was a lot of money sometimes 10 it
was it 20 bucks with a 10. I'm trying to
think how much the
iron I remember what I remember most in
the early 90s when I worked at a record
store I remember our CD prices going up
from 15.99 to 17.99 and everyone
freaking the [__] out about it and
yelling at me about it like I had any
[__] like I was like yeah it's me I
changed the prices sorry what the [__]
it's like I make [__] minimum wage in
this [__] leave me alone
discovering new music you could go on
YouTube right and lift the track like
for free and like listen it's like Oh I
like that I'm gonna go see that band or
whatever yeah you had to [__] put
your money where your mouth was you had
to [__] place that bet you had to lay
that you had to lay that [__]
Franklin or was it a Benjamin
to the 20. who's in 2017 who's on the
20. I think it was banjo I think it was
I think I think it's Ben Franklin I
thought Ben Franklin
it's a Jackson Jackson
yeah
Ben Franklin he's on the 100 yeah 100
yeah and then you take the album home
and it [__] sucks and you're like oh
[__]
yeah you know yeah true
Oscar is here hey Oscar what's up the
90s was not a good time for horror it
was not
um
honestly at the time I thought it was
just me but in hindsight yeah that would
and I'm not saying that like some good
[__] movies didn't come out in the
90s because they did
a soft spot for the 90s people don't
rate the people will get too hard on the
90s no well the 90s because the over
yeah and I'm not saying that I'm not
arguing that at all there was a star
came out no as far as like horror movies
yeah okay well there were some good
witch was kind of a sensation in the
night well that was 99 yeah that was
late night I guess so yeah so
um I mean there was good [__] that came
out in the 90s I'm not saying that but
I'm one thing I will say is that the
overarching uh impression that I got at
least from a horror movie standpoint
really from that decade was that it was
just very concerned with
being derivative particularly after 1996
after scream came out and actually I saw
scream in the theater and I quite
enjoyed it because it was like an
updated slasher movie but it was also
kind of it was a slasher movie in its
own right and it was like gory and
entertaining but it was also kind of
parodying it like in a really clever way
but then after that came out then we got
like a whole rash of like slasher
rip-offs and they just like were
dumb they just like weren't that and
then like late 90s and early 2000s it
was just like all remakes of old [__]
and I was just kind of like and
everything like was CGI to [__] death
one thing that I will
like one thing that I'll point out is
like the thing that I hated about the
the 90s
was they remade
The Haunting
which is probably I mean in my top five
favorite horror movies ever this based
on The Haunting of Hill House by Shirley
Jackson they made the movie Robert Wise
directed it came out in 1963. one of the
quintessential examples of horror being
scary without showing anything it's
genius
it doesn't show anything but it's still
[__] creepy
and it was great and then they remade it
in the 90s
with [__] Catherine Zeta Jones and uh
I think Owen Wilson was in it Liam
Neeson might have been in it Lily Taylor
was in it and I went to see it in the
theater against my better judgment and
it was awful they just cgi'd the [__]
out of it they showed everything they
just had like all these and I was just
like what the you just missed the entire
[__] point of the book and of the
story and of this is not scary it's just
stupid and ridiculous and everything is
just a big everything had to have a
million like CGI demons in it and I was
just over it
it's not scary
well 90s I got a soft spot for the
fashion for the music
that came out the the 90s fashion
especially what they called on
alternative fashion was very good
you had [__]
boots made by destroy and pentagon
you had certain
I like the female fashion because they
they still even in the 90s it didn't
offer much for guys you were really kind
of have you were scraping up trying to
put something cool together
but I just remember the girls man
[__] how how good they looked back
then you had
looks that today would probably be
called fairy core it was like what
Courtney Love would wear Mazzy Star they
were kind of like these dresses with
patterns on them and they how would you
describe them Jan [__] uh with
[__] [__] velor type boots that
were like gothy looking boots and
[__] what were those shoes that they
wore fluvogs
and they had it was a good it was kind
of like something switchblade Symphony
would wear or you know Courtney Love and
Mazzy Star well they had a lot of those
kind of like baby doll dresses
yeah yeah [__] Babes in Toyland that
bad you know they had that they had a
certain look I thought it looked great I
did that was one of the things I did
like about the music of the night I did
like the whole Riot girl thing and I did
like that all of that yeah I did like
the shoegaze I like that and then you
had
even in Mississippi just these [__]
hot
hot [__] [__] rave girls and jenkos
and belly shirts and tongue rings and
belly button rings and [__] you never
knew what their hair was gonna look like
and they were
it was it was just a good time
and I remember you know during that time
I was in my 20s late 20s and it felt
like at the time that the entire world
was coming together and at the world
that I wished was going to happen was
starting to happen that's what it felt
like
it's like oh man the Fashion's getting
better [__] even music is getting
better and then like even the pop music
was pretty good and I wouldn't buy it
but I was listening to it like remember
Prodigy came out yeah I'm gonna snap my
[__] up and [__] and uh they still play
that at mannequin yeah and then
even some of their real [__]
even some of the real [__] [__] that
I thought was mainstream like Beastie
Boys started to sound real good from
like Intergalactic yeah remember that
uh it was just
it was still very Mall goth though you
know what I mean but in a certain way
you had to begin you had the first few
seasons of [__] um
of uh
what was the name of that damn cartoon
South Park South Park was out
it was just it was just a good time it
was a happy time I liked the 90s
there's a type of mystery too the
internet was out we'll see well I get on
the internet and find new [__] and
[__] the internet wasn't very big
back then it wasn't and it wasn't
mainstream you know like your mom
couldn't do it you know I mean your
grandma definitely couldn't do it
nowadays anybody could surf around
it wasn't like that back then well I
mean nowadays you see [__] 80 year
olds with [__] yeah smartphones right
yeah they can they can get around inside
the internet but not back in these days
but well the thing about it is that well
see the thing that I didn't like about
the night in general like I said I'm not
saying like everything that came out in
the 90s sucks because obviously that's
not true that's not true of any decade
but the thing I didn't like about the
90s was that a lot of the culture seemed
it just seemed very try hard
you know what I mean and I don't like
try hard I don't like when people are
like trying to like pay attention to me
it was very much like that I remember
the younger people everything is Extreme
and I was just like please stop it no
one wants to pay attention to you I was
a little bit older than you you're
and like people
living to me so I know what you're
talking about yeah like everyone's like
we're so crazy I'm just like you know
yeah that was really painful
people my own age you know what I mean
like mid-20s to late
that's what I mean it's like I said that
whole thing was just like very very dry
yeah if you guys know what Madison
Height is there's the fans of Maryland
Vance or the spooky kids as we called
them back in the old days yeah
Marilyn Manson and we're like ah aren't
they darling yeah he's from Florida and
he's a friend of a DJ like an old Brian
Warner Brian Warner
but uh
I still like the I still like the era
though I liked it
I don't know like I said I'm not a big
I'm not a big fan of like try hard [__]
I don't like it if the costume was great
during that time
some of the music was good I did like a
lot of the goth rock at the time
not as much as I like in the 80s but
well now I I haven't been since I wasn't
gonna be like a raver or anything but I
liked that they were around they had
their own thing going on yeah
yeah that was that was a thing for a
minute wasn't it gravers yeah ravers
which is kind of like a like a god
version which
so every now and then you go to the golf
club and there'd be that one person that
had the big pants and like and like
spinning the glow sticks yeah yeah and
everyone was like what the [__] yeah
here we are with this [__] yeah you
always had that one person that topic
invented that
that yeah that's what I'm saying yeah
and I was not a fan
but yeah that's that's what I mean
that's what I mean when I didn't like
this was involved
involved I know you told me my friend
was named Melissa LaVoy she's from
Mississippi and she was a manager of the
Hot Topic
in Gulfport Mississippi
and she was on a big [__]
call with like some other managers from
the Regents and
and they were talking about we're gonna
take Rave and mix it with goth because
they were selling both of those clothing
lines out of the Hot Topic and they were
all laughing and these are like goth
people running hot topic
they're like yeah it's like we're gonna
make those big juice recipes
they're gonna be goth verses with
[__] bondage but we kind of shot
ourselves in the dick yeah with that
whole situation
it was a woman that came up with that
idea it was [__] it was Michelle's
regional manager she manages all of
everything from the south and on the
[__] East Coast
and she called it she goes we think
they'll sell
and then they even ran a damn contest to
like
if you get a customer dress them up this
way and take a picture whoever's got the
best who's got the the most ridiculous
looking customer will give you a
thousand dollar [__] bonus I was just
[__] so there we they were using
[__] regular people as [__]
oh man they were trolling people back
then I don't think people realized it
though yeah Hot Topic made that look as
a because they they were smart they knew
that people would buy that as tasteless
as that was
they knew that they would buy they did
they made that a thing
yeah they started seeing that the clubs
and I was man that was that was a whole
aesthetic we only knew the meal the Hot
Topic had when they came up with that
[__] they probably still wear that shirt
it's probably I still wear that anyway
yeah John Gore said alien sex fiend kind
of created that neon glow goth aesthetic
first yeah you're right about that but
they didn't they didn't come at it the
same way yeah though because Alien Sex
Fiend were weird as [__] yeah and they
just kind of did that because they were
kind of very into the whole uh
psychedelic yeah angle
um so I think they did it just
tangentially because of that but Hot
Topic had a different take on it
the The Goth scene was pretty big they
sold clothes for the godsend they also
so sold clothes to the Rave scene and
those two scenes didn't get along they
were pretty much the opposite yeah so
they said well we'll merge them into the
same day yeah
and we were and you know meanwhile like
people were like I said have been around
since the 80s are just like or the 70s
or just been like what are you doing
like that's not allowed we don't like
those people
that were [__] five years younger
than us showing up in those outfits
a Graver and all of the all of us old
farts were just sitting here
yeah we're listening to oh these kids
today we're we're wearing [__] velvet
velvet [__] shirts and [__]
dresses and [__]
PVC pants and they were like looking at
these like what are they even doing what
are they even doing yeah and then like
still on the interview with a vampire
well the weird thing well the weird
thing about it was that
they were buying a lot of the music that
was so a lot of this like the kids
they'd have like all these piercings in
their face and like they'd wear them but
then they were listening to like Blink
182 and I'm just like what the [__] are
you but do you even know what you're
doing what are you doing
that's not right
[Laughter]
they're just like listen to like pop
punk yeah and I'm just like I don't even
know what you're doing what are you even
doing what is your thing I don't get it
but yeah so so that's the thing I just
kind of feel like that the 90s to me is
just was like a decade long
[__] like that like just me going what
are you doing I don't understand but
yeah
uh Poe says is that a coffin-shaped gem
I guess he's talking about maybe that
yes it is
it's just like a coffin-shaped ring and
then that's that one's kind of like what
do you call that
like spiky kind of
and then that was like little razor
blades and then that one's like a little
snake
I just get these like cheap and like
sets you know what I mean they got
little skulls and all that kind of [__]
on it
uh posted hey Debbie Gibson meshed with
the Circle Jerks okay yeah that did kind
of work out I was surprised
I didn't expect that to work out
but it kind of did so you know
all right so Thomas needs to be going
quiet so I guess we're gonna I've been
off for a long time do you wanna go
watch Poltergeist yeah you hungry
yeah I got more of that Thai curry oh we
should get some more of that he made
like a really good tiger what even did
you put in that well I did put peanut
butter in there well I could tell yeah
that's why it was so good it was yellow
yellow curry paste Thai yellow curry oh
see that's my favorite and I put it the
kind of the the curry paste that comes
in that little yellow package the little
yellow yeah
vegetables out of the garden
the onions did come out of the garden
though bought those the chicken
and then I put about uh a cup that's I
made a big fat of it put a cup of
[__] peanut butter in that [__] well
yeah yeah see that's kind of my favorite
one that you do I think that curry with
the peanut butter in yeah because it's
like not super hot but it's like really
nice and savory and it's got like
potatoes like sweet potatoes and [__]
like that all right so we're gonna
shut it down
um so we'll be back on Monday talking
about a movie I don't know which movie
where it's gonna be like it'll just be
whatever we watch over the weekend which
we haven't decided yet uh so hopefully
you guys can join us for that hopefully
you guys have had a good time hanging
out with us tonight getting drunk and
talking about random [__] uh so
we'll see you again on Monday evening
good night